Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Du hast schon gehört jetzt ist akk auch noch auf dem rückzug.
Und wenn es jetzt doch friedrich merz wird dann will ich meine fünf euro zurück.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertneununddreißig und ja wir schreiben den elften elften februar.
So sieht's aus genuss und fünf euro kannst du kannst du kannst vergessen die liste.
Krieg ich nur zwei sechzehnte von fünf euro kriege ich weil so eine typische wie lange ist eine durchschnittliche cdu-vorsitz also gemessen an merkel und.
Das ist ganz interessant dass du das sagst bei der cdu ist es immer so entweder.
Halten die viele viele jahre oder nur ein paar monate.
Geht es immer immer im pingpong und tatsächlich ist akk jetzt so voll im nachdem es sehr lange merkel war
hat sie als nachfolgerin quasi überhaupt nicht lange gehalten was darauf hinausläuft dass der oder die nachfolgerin,
dann wieder so eine ewige zeit hinlegt es sei denn die zeiten haben sich komplett geändert und nichts gilt mir was früher mal war das kann ja auch sein dann ist es anders.
Kennst du diesen trick wie man sich die die lang und die kurzen monate merkt so mit den knöcheln an der hand.
Meinst du februar und märz.
Ja
Dann bist du irgendwann im juni juli august september du musst ja immer wieder zurück weil einmal folgender zwei zwei einunddreißig tägige monate aufeinander so sitzen die bestimmt auch bei der cdu da bei den wahlen denken so oh nee das ist jetzt ein tal.
Da das war die akk hin nächsten nächsten vorsitzenden brauchen wir wieder ja verrückte sache kommen wir glaube ich glaube ich gleich nochmal zu.
Ok schalt ja bei der cdu sozusagen.
Wir haben feedback bekommen.
Ah
Von filter johannes filter der und sagte ja hier wird ja lange über in die media gesprochen und so ne aber tatsächlich ist das analog zu.
Alter media passiert und alter media war quasi das indimedia von rechts in die zwanzig sechzehn zugemacht wurde.
Und das war also alter media war so ein bisschen orientiert an indimedia ne wollten irgendwie.
Sowas halt ich für antisemitische propaganda und rassistische inhalte schaffen und.
Deren plattform wurde ähnlich geschlossen mit ähnlicher juristischen vorgehen geschlossen.
In die media jetzt kann man sich natürlich wieder länger darunter darüber unterhalten dass was für ziele eine plattform tatsächlich hat ja,
und ob das der richtige weg ist so auf eine webseite zuzugehen ich würde im zweifelsfall dass auch bei alter medio media,
nicht unbedingt richtig finden.
Also mit genauso im sinne von wir machen euch jetzt einfach mal zu aber ihr könnt jetzt nicht widersprechen weil dann gibt er ja zu dass ihr zu dieser äußert schon gehört und deswegen kann er keinen anspruch erheben oder inwiefern ähnlich.
Also was ich hier lese ist im märz zwanzig elf wurde axel möller wer das total neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig als störtebecker netz gegründet hatte als redaktionell verantwortlicher betreiber der seite zu einer geldstrafe von dreitausend euro verurteilt,
seine berufung gegen das unterziehen zu zurück.
Am fünften august wurde die in den usa registrierte domain der webseite abgeschaltet ähm.
Dann wurden sie zur haftstrafen verurteilt wegen volksverhetzung verwenden von kennzeichen verfassungsfeindlicher organisationen und aufruf zu straftaten,
sie klingt aber dann doch ein bisschen anders.
Würde ich auch meinen als ich meine gibt's konkrete dinge so ich weiß ja nicht so dass bei indimedia.
Mölders mölders haftstrafe möllers haftstrafe wurde im märz zwanzig dreizehn wegen weiterer volksverhetzung der straftaten und ein jahr verlängert.
Wenn man nicht meinen der herr müller.
Und dann hatten sie sind natürlich irgendwie u s amerikaner die für die domain verantwortlich sind und in russland hausten.
Ah ja aber doch hier guck mal hier,
am siebenundzwanzigsten januar das war jetzt quasi noch nur das vor geschehen ja als sie ihre domains verloren haben und die redaktionell verantwortlichen,
verknackt wurden am siebenundzwanzigsten januar zweitausendsechzehn ist auch das worauf der johannes hingewiesen hatte führte das bundeskriminalamt im zuge von ermittlungen der bundesliga,
anwaltschaft in karlsruhe wegen bildung einer kriminellen vereinigung hausdurchsuchung bei mehreren personen aus der führungsebene von alter media deutschland in vier bundesländern durch.
Administratoren wurden festgenommen.
Server wurde abgeschaltet und bundesinnenminister thomas de maizière verbot nach paragraph drei des vereins gesetzes die betreiber,
erklärte das portal förderung ermöglichen die verbreitung übelster rassistischer und fremdenfeindlicher kommentare und beiträge in denen straftaten gegen ausländer verteidigt zu straftaten aufgefordert und taten.
Nationalsozialismus gerechtfertigt werden das sei mit der fdp nicht vereinbar ja ja dann danke für den hinweis.
Ja aber das was hier vorgeworfen wird es dann schon nochmal ein bisschen anders gelagert als.
Also immerhin waren es mal immerhin waren es tatsächlich auch kriminelle also die waren ja immerhin schon verurteilte kriminelle jetzt ist natürlich schon noch die äh die frage wie es dann im detail aussieht.
Nicht in dem links unten ist ja nicht in demselben maße wie das hier heißt rassistische und fremdenfeindliche kommentare veröffentlicht worden und straftaten gegen ausländer verteidigt worden also das ist ja sozusagen komplett andere sachlage.
Ja rechtlich natürlich nicht unbedingt weil das die bundesrepublik deutschland ja dem dem hufeisen anhängt.
Reisen wird heute auch noch eine länge rolle spielen.
Ja das hufeisen da wo alles was irgendwie nicht gartenzaun hat ist halt irgendwie extrem.
Also hufeisentheorie ist das was an annegret kramp-karrenbauer eher auch so stark vertritt ne also.
Rechts und links ist beides schlecht nur da wo ich wenn es richtig und naja aber ok danke johannes für den hinweis,
und stellt uns natürlich,
für die vor die frage ob wir das jetzt bei alter media gut finden und bei in die medien nicht wenn wir bei indimedia vor allem darüber gesprochen dass das ding wenn dann als medium.
Behandelt werden muss weil was auch seine open posting gedanken angeht und.
Wir befinden uns da insgesamt natürlich immer so ein bisschen und das wird glaube ich auch heute in der sendung ist dann nochmal eine rolle spielen,
in der haftung ist plattformbetreiber ne also wenn du eine plattform betreibst für welche inhalte.
Haftest oder und für welche nicht und allen ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo klar dass da irgendwo eine grenze verläuft zwischen,
du hast irgendwie eine plattform was sagen nennen wir sie youtube und da wird irgendwas hochgeladen sehr sehr viele deiner inhalte sind egal einige wenige sind illegal und du gehst irgendwie damit um.
Oder du hast eine plattform die dem einzigen zweck dient dass dort bestimmte verbotene dinge geschehen oder.
Auf teilen der webseite kategorien vorgehalten werden auf den bestimmte illegale dinge geschehen und.
Das wird uns heute glaube ich durch die sendung immer immer wieder mal uns voll also diese frage wird uns immer wieder beschäftigen wenn wir,
uns das anschauen insbesondere mit sie urheberrechts debatte anschauen wo quasi gesagt wurde ok wenn du eine plattform hast dann musst du,
von vornherein hattest du für jede urheberrechtsverletzung wieder hochgeladen wird vorher filtern bevor überhaupt irgendwas online stellt was andere dir schicken diese debatten haben wir wir haben aber auch,
eine debatte über wikileaks wir haben eben eine debatte über indimedia oder alter media.
Und noch andere inhalte zu denen wir im laufe der sendung kommen und ich denke das wird heute eine gute sendung um darüber mal relativ lange zu diskutieren.
Dann lass uns da auch mal vorstoßen in diese segmente.
Plattformen sind ein stichwort in dieser sendung und.
Eine plattform die als plattform damals angefangen hat war ja wikileaks,
irgendwann in den späten zweitausender jahren so weltweit,
der öffentlichkeit präsentiert wir haben das hier in anderen sendungen schon ausführlicher zusammengefasst.
Hat der wikileaks so sein den zenit und höhepunkt seines wirkens würde ich sagen ungefähr im jahr zweitausendzehn als es ja eine reihe an sehr ja sagen wir mal veröffentlichung gab die die,
welt erschüttert haben das besondere an wikileaks war,
in seiner vorstellung und von seinem selbstverständnis her bis zu diesem,
veröffentlichungen in zweitausendzehn eigentlich dass sie gesagt haben wir sind eine ja eine leading plattform hier werden sachen hochgeladen wir prüfen irgendwie grob ob die echt sind und wir veröffentlichen sie,
unredigiert unzensiert und unkommentiert was eine ja,
sagen wir mal ein ein sehr in allen formen serie radikaler ansatz war der natürlich,
auch eine reihe an kritik von journalistinnen und journalisten eingefahren hat schon vor den großen veröffentlichungen.
Weil natürlich die journalistinnen und journalisten sagen hier unser job ist da draußen gibt es,
zu viele fakten zu viele dinge die passieren zu viele wahrheiten die eigentliche
aufgabe die eigentliche leistung die man erbringen muss ist diese dinge einzuordnen und wikileaks hat eigentlich gesagt ne arschlecken das könnt ihr machen
unsere aufgabe ist geheimnisse zu tage zu befördern das war so der ursprüngliche ansatz von wikileaks.
Und dann kam es zu den,
historischen veröffentlichungen insbesonderes des coletta mörder videos also das video in dem ein kampfhubschrauber.
Einsatz aus sicht glaube ich der piloten oder der board kamera dieses dieses hubschraubers gefilmt ist wo die auf.
Eigentlich relativ klar erkennbar zivilisten schießen auch mit kindern und relativ eindeutig sind die personen auf die da geschossen wird nicht in kampfhandlungen verwickelt.
Ja und vor allem auch leute die nachdem die ersten angriffe stattgefunden haben versuchen denen die betroffen waren zu helfen und die wurden dann auch noch nieder gemäht.
Also ein ein eindeutiges ein eindeutiges kriegsverbrechen dem zum opfer gefallen ist ein reuters-journalisten der.
Glaube ich eine kamera mit einem großen teleobjektiv umhängen hatte die sie dann nachher irgendwie so umgedeutet haben als du das sieht aber aus wie eine knarre oder so.
Aber es war eindeutig diese leute standen mitten auf offener straße arglos ging da irgendwie zu so einem auto und waren jetzt nicht in kampfhandlungen verwickelt und.
Dieses video hatte hat league veröffentlicht und es schien mir wenn ich das richtig erinnere die erste,
redigierte und kommentierte veröffentlichung zu sein weil dieses video war natürlich also man konnte jetzt nichts erkennen man musste halt erklären das ist hier dieser reuters-journalisten wir betrauert haben letztes jahr oder vor zwei jahren und,
das ist die aufnahme von dem und dem tag und das was sie jetzt hören ist hier dieser pilot und so ne das heißt sie haben da angefangen.
Zu kommentieren und das journalistisch aufzuarbeiten eigentlich meine ich mit dem collateral mörder video.
Oder drückt mich da die die erinnerung was die reihenfolge angeht.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht mehr so ganz genau auf jeden fall war das ein großer.
Wechsel also vorher hatten sie ja oft auch einfach dokumente mehr oder weniger unredigiert rausgehauen und dafür auch ordentlich kritik bekommen das hat sich dann bei diesem diplomatie calls auch nochmal ein stück weit,
wiederholt also zumindest fragwürdig war da alles so ordentlich redigiert wurde bei dem video war es halt wirklich.
Eine konzertierte aktion dass auch wirklich auf eine art und weise der öffentlichkeit zu präsentieren die halt mehr ist als nur hier guck mal wir haben hier ein video kannst du runterladen schau's dir an mach dir selber deine gedanken.
Ich glaube das ist auch dokumentiert da gab es eine,
in verschiedenen büchern glaube ich niedergeschrieben ein ein treffen von verschiedenen leuten die halt an dieser veröffentlichung mitgearbeitet haben eine mindestens eine der person hast du ja auch mal interview tim.
Das kann man mit rob,
zur sprache wo es halt eigentlich um diese ganze verbindung der deutschen und der holländischen hacker ging,
und unter anderem kam mir dann halt auch noch darauf zur sprache weil es gerade aktuell war und rock eben einer derjenigen waren die daran beteiligt waren diese veröffentlichung vorzubereiten,
hundertzweiundsiebzig holland und die hacker.
Ja da saßen da hatten sich dann offenbar mehrere leute nicht alle sind glaube ich öffentlich benannt in island getroffen und haben dieses video da da die
flankieren den recherchen und aufarbeitung und so weiter vorangetrieben warum erkläre ich das nochmal so ausführlich ja weil,
kurz darauf kam wenn mich meine erinnerung nicht drückt dann die veröffentlichung,
diplomatie cambrills also einer riesigen menge an botschaften depression die us-amerikanische botschaften überall aus aller welt irgendwie nach hause geschickt hatten und,
in denen sich eine reihe natürlich auch an skandalen verbarg,
in deutschland war der medienpartner für die veröffentlichung.
Meine ich der spiegel so holger stark und so waren da
damals die leute die da viel mit felix zusammengearbeitet haben die deutsche veröffentlichung war leider eher so ein bisschen auf boulevard niveau und konzentrierte sich
meine ich im spiegel-titel so ein bisschen drauf so so reden die amis über oder so schreibt die amis bei uns wenn sie
wenn wir nicht zugucken und haben irgendwie so deren einschätzungen charakterliche einschätzung deutscher politiker
irgendwie zitiert in anderen ländern gab es da durchaus brisantes aufarbeitung dieser cambrills.
Und.
Dann kamen noch die fdp wo also auch wieder eine ganze reihe an dokumentationen des kriegsgeschehen in afghanistan und so und in all diesen veröffentlichungen hat league
von dieser ursprünglich sehr radikalen,
veröffentlichungsprozess axis sich entfernt hinzu der zusammenarbeit mit guardian mit spiegel mit den mit dem großen medienhäusern.
Die dann danach journalistischen standards auch was weiß ich die name von informanten geschwärzt haben dinge eingeordnet haben.
Auch die ursprüngliche veröffentlichungen,
strategie von felix war so ein bisschen wir knallen die sachen da raus und wir gucken dann was andere damit tun ja wie andere journalistinnen und journalisten die aufarbeiten.
Snowden nur um dann mal,
einige jahre weiter vorzuspulen hat sich dann auch dazu entschieden letztendlich sich für seine veröffentlichungen eine,
ja medienpartner in dem sinne zu suchen die eine veröffentlichung strategie führen ja also die snowden veröffentlichung wurden ja
über fast zwei jahre getrieben da kam immer wieder was neues das war nicht einfach das wurde nicht einmal alles auf einmal verpufft,
wie das in meinen augen eigentlich mit den fc und auch mit den.
Mit den botschaften depression eigentlich passiert ist sondern der hat auch gesagt ok hier wir geben das in die hände von leuten die das einordnen recherchieren veröffentlichen und die vielleicht auch eine veröffentlichung strategie haben also ich würde auch im rückblickend sagen
diese massen veröffentlichung von wikileaks.
Eigentlich unsinnig waren die haben die sind quasi verpufft ne also die haben nicht.
Das volle potential entfaltet was in der masse der daten drin war.
Ja das ist sagen wir mal so ein bisschen auf die falsche
annahme gewesen dass wenn so ein füllhorn an informationen da ist dass ich dann schon alle darauf stürzen würden und das aus werten würden und sich nichts schöneres vorstellen können als diese quellen zu haben
und hat sich halt eher gezeigt dass es wichtiger also eine gewisse medienstrategie zu fahren und den fokus immer auf bestimmte sachen zu
lenken weil man am ende auch so einen journalisten her damit einfach komplett überfordern kann die sich bestenfalls eine sache rauspicken und dann ist das ding halt irgendwie auch schon wieder durch.
Genau und und journalisten und journalistin sind sehr darauf bedacht ist ja auch verständlich wenn sie sich viel arbeit machen irgendwie sicherzustellen dass sie,
keine konkurrenz dabei haben also versuchen stories exklusiv zu bekommen wenn du irgendwie wenn wir vom tc veröffentlichungen,
machen größere was weiß ich jetzt irgendwie staatstrojaner oder wahl wenn wir damit mit den journalistinnen vorgespräche führen ist eine der ersten fragen die die stellen wer arbeitet dann noch dran,
und da spielt für die eine rolle einfach auch um zu wissen wie hoch kann ich das aufhängen wieviel zeit kann ich hier investieren und wenn du den sagst naja pass auf.
Wir arbeiten mit,
drei leuten jetzt gerade zusammen den wir die informationen vorabschicken den rest veröffentlichen wir in einer pm dann ist das was anderes als wenn du sagst wir telefonieren wir sprechen gerade mit zwanzig du kannst davon ausgehen dass die dann,
insgesamt weniger zeit da rein investieren also diese zusammenarbeit mit den medien von wikileaks vater.
Der richtige weg und trotzdem diesem diese menge an informationen war.
Unsinnig also da da ist das potenzial nicht voll entfaltet worden das hat wiederum snowden gelernt und das dann besser gemacht warum rede ich da so lange drauf rum.
War das eine relativ große rolle spielt für die aktuelle juristische situation von julian assange denn.
Wie wir wissen ist er inzwischen in großbritannien in haft und zwar,
erwarten sie erwartet ihn ein ende februar beginnendes auslieferungs verfahren in richtung der usa und die usa,
wollen ihnen anklang wollen ihn ausliefern weil sie ihm vorwerfen an diesem veröffentlichungen,
mitgewirkt zu haben in krimineller weise und dass diese veröffentlichung selber nicht journalistisch waren spezifisch wird ihm vorgeworfen dass er chelsea menning die wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche für alle drei,
veröffentlichung die quelle war anleitung oder,
unterstützung angeboten zu haben ein passwort zu knacken und damit wäre er.
Irgendwo so im im strafbar ich fünf jahre nach dem computer fror interviews act
da sie aber jetzt chelsea manning als spionin einstufen und ihn dann zur beihilfe blickt er eigentlich in den usa auf irgendwie sowas wie hundert noch was jahre die akkumuliert ja irgendwie die
die strafen.
Schatzi manning wie wir wissen hat für genau die fälle um dies jetzt bei julian assange geht ich glaube ihr urteil waren fünfunddreißig jahre ne und,
weiß ich ja also habe ich gar nicht so ungefähr im kopf und sie wurde hier nach sieben jahren begnadigt von barack obama kurz vor ende seiner amtszeit.
Und sitzt jetzt aber wieder im knast in beugehaft weil sie halt möchten,
dass sie über julian assange aussagen macht und sie lehnt es nicht nur absolut sagt auch seite auch schon alles dazu gesagt was dazu zu sagen gibt und mehr gibt es nicht und ja hat da jetzt sozusagen nochmal ein separates problem.
Genau sie hat also die ist jetzt auch wieder weiß nicht wie viele hundert tage schon wieder in haft in beugehaft weil sie sich einer grandios stellen soll das gleiche was übrigens auch julian assange passieren soll kommen wir gleich nochmal zu,
kurz nach diesem veröffentlichungen über kriegsverbrechen der usa.
Zumindest was das collateral mörder video und was die angeht und dann diese botschaft depression.
Begibt es sich dass zwei frauen in kurzer folge so wird es medial berichtet weltweit,
vergewaltigungs- vorwürfe gegen julian assange erheben eigentlich das passt so,
erstaunlich weil es passte immer zu den verschwörungstheorien die natürlich kursierten also es war völlig klar mit den veröffentlichungen von wikileaks irgendwie zweitausendzehn es war völlig klar dass das.
Dass die sich auf eine rache gefasst machen müssen die,
sehr sehr ekelig sein wird und natürlich hat man am einige gesagt ja der wird halt einfach irgendwann unter mysteriösen unter mysteriösen umständen irgendwie sterben oder einen unfall haben oder so,
das wäre natürlich wiederum viel zu.
Viel zu auffällig gewesen also dass ich eigentlich schon immer so viele dachten naja es gibt ja viele leute viele wege wie man menschen in misskredit bringen kann und so das mit den frauen ist irgendwie eine der einfachsten möglichkeiten
dann kam aber diese vorwürfe wunder medial berichtet und dann denkst du dir natürlich auch weißt du wenn dann auf einmal,
da die rede ist von sexuellem,
sexueller belästigung sexuellen ja straftaten dann denkst du natürlich auch ja das denkt sich ja eigentlich auch.
Niemand aus du kriegst jetzt keine frau unbedingt dazu so etwas,
einfach zu erzählen ohne dass es irgendeine ohne dass es irgendeinen wahren kern hat
und es ist teilten sich das lager dann schon sehr früh im prinzip in diese ich über spitze das jetzt mal die einen die sachen das ist alles eine reine verschwörung gegen julian assange und die anderen die sagten naja
also irgendwas wird er ja schon gewesen sein und der kann ja ein grandioser anführer einer legging plattform sein.
Und ein arschloch ja die meisten leute sagen er ist beides die mit ihm zu tun hatten und und ähm.
Dieses thema beschäftigte halt alle so klar.
Und alle waren jetzt auf einmal experten und expertinnen für die beurteilung von sexualstraftaten.
Wir wissen wie's weiterging assange ist.
Unter sorge dass diese schwedischen vorwürfe gegen ihn vorwände sind um ihn in die usa auszuliefern nach
zunächst
berlin dann großbritannien geflohen wurde dann in großbritannien irgendwie festgesetzt im unter hausarrest weil er unter in einem europäischen haftbefehl sich befand und floh dann.
In die equatorianische botschaft beantragte asyl bekam dort sieben jahre lang asyl bis die regierung wechselte und die auf druck der usa sich entschied ihn rauszuwerfen was jetzt vor wenigen.
Monaten eigentlich geschehen ist so viel war bekannt und es war auch schon immer so bekannt dass irgendwie so also mit den vergewaltigungen da es war jetzt auf jeden fall,
so klar dass das jetzt keine schauermärchen vergewaltigung waren wo jetzt irgendwie den frauen im wald aufgelauert wäre oder so aber es richtet.
Es gab da so allerhand komische.
Begebenheiten äußerungen und vorstellungen zu aber irgendwie ist auch klar dass das ist ja eine irgendwie einen wahren kern haben musste und.
Stellt sich raus stimmt so ein bisschen beides denn jetzt gab es eine veröffentlichung von der website republik punkt c du hast dich da mal ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt was das ist.
Der republik im prinzip so auch eine leser getragene,
publikation also wo journalisten sich nicht von
sponsoren beziehungsweise anzeigenkunden bezahlen lassen wollen so unabhängig arbeiten möchten ähnliche modelle gibt's ja auch in deutschland konkret hat sich glaube ich dieses projekt auch,
wiederum vorbild genommen an einer ähnlichen geschichte in holland läuft schon seit ein paar jahren,
und ja das ist im prinzip so ein bisschen vielleicht mit korrektiv zu vergleichen herr bitte keine ahnung ob die auch eine ähnliche ähnliche themen ausrichtung und journalistische,
generelle ausrichtung haben aber zumindest von der finanzierung vom anspruch her läuft es in diese richtung,
wobei man auch dazu sagen muss deren funding läuft derzeit auch nur noch bis ende märz glaube ich und dann wird's auch schwierig mit der zukunft,
ja aber das das ist sozusagen glaube ich das wie man republik c ein sortieren sollte es eine reine online-publikum aktion.
So und die veröffentlichen ein sehr ausführliches interview mit nils mälzer nils melzer ist der un sonderberichterstatter für folter.
Ähm und ein eigentlich ein professor in.
Rechtswissenschaftler ist er.
In welcher an welcher universität habe ich ganz vergessen.
Die universität in glasgow.
Achso glasgow aber er ist eigentlich schweizer ne ah ja okay.
Wollten wir übrigens eigentlich auch zum kongress einladen hat aber nicht geklappt jetzt kann ich's ja sagen so der.
Berichtet also er wurde angesprochen von den anwälten von julian assange die sagten hier dieser fall und so und er meinte er kommen keine ahnung ne,
also anfangs diesen fall auch so ein bisschen jetzt nicht als allererstes auf der liste gehabt weil er dachte ja komm ist klar dass die sich gerade um alles bemühen dann hat er aber irgendwie sich doch mal mit assange getroffen paar sachen geschaut angeschaut und
berichtet jetzt davon und jetzt sagt er tja diese.
Diese vergewaltigungs- sachen in schweden die liefen ungefähr so ab es gibt zwei frauen die da diese vorwürfe erheben.
Diese beiden frauen kannten sich auch da da geht er jetzt nicht so drauf ein,
aber das spielt glaube ich auch nicht so eine große rolle nehmen nennen sie jetzt mal.
Erste frau und zweite frau weil die bis heute ich glaube die wurden irgendwann mal gedopt aber eigentlich sind die sind die namen nicht nicht öffentlich geläufig also am zwanzigsten august betritt die erste frau in begleitung der zweiten frau,
den
polizeiposten in stockholm und diese erste frau sagt also sie hat jetzt irgendwie einvernehmlichen geschlechtsverkehr mit schönen assange gehabt allerdings,
ohne kondom und sie hätte jetzt angst dass sie sich mit irgendwas infiziert haben könnte zum beispiel hiv und,
fragt die polizei ob sie den assange irgendwie dazu verpflichten könne ein hiv-test zu machen.
Weil sie in großer sorge ist und die polizei schreibt die aussage irgendwie auf informiert die staatsanwaltschaft und noch während,
dieser befragung sagt die polizei ja wir werden den assange also jetzt wegen vergewaltigung,
festen heben so und die frau sagt boah,
krass dass dann dann dann beende ich jetzt hier die befragung ich unterschreibe diese aussage nicht.
Ich und ich beteilige mich daran nicht weil das ist nicht mein wunsch ja ich möchte nur dass der ihn wieder sehr test macht und weigert sich also die befragung weiterzuführen schickt,
aus der polizeistation an eine freundin eine sms und sagt ich will den überhaupt nicht beschuldigen ich will nur dass er diesen hiv-test macht aber die polizei will ihn ganz offensichtlich in die finger kriegen,
die frau die sie begleitet hat wurde an dem tag gar nicht angehört.
Und die kommt irgendwie später noch mal irgendwie zu dieser polizei.
Und ihre situation war die hatte ihre wohnung sofa verkauft surft an assange während sie selber nicht da war ist aber dann irgendwie früher zurückgekommen und dann hätte der.
Hätte der assange irgendwie zurückgekommen also sie ist zurück gekommen war noch da und da hat sie gesagt er ist aber gar kein problem wir schlafen einfach beide zusammen in meinem bett und
komm zum geschlechtsverkehr und irgendwie am ende ist das kondom kaputt.
Sie sagt wohl bei ihrer ersten befragung aus dass sie davon ausgeht dass er das absichtlich kaputt gemacht hätte
sie sagt aber gleichzeitig sie hätte es erst im nachhinein gemerkt dass es kommt kaputt ist wenn er das kaputt gemacht hätte dann ist das ein strafbar,
eine straftat die finde ich auch zurecht klar ich meine da geht mit,
mit einer verletzung der bedingungen ein unter denen man sich irgendwie auf den verkehr geeinigt hat und mit verschiedenen risiken.
Von hiv-infektion bis hin zur schwangerschaft ne das können es ist auf jeden fall straff strafrechtlich relevantes verhalten wenn es.
Absichtlich passiert und dass solche kondome gehen auch mal unabsichtlich kaputt das kommt wie man hört in den besten familien vor.
Ja da kommt die familie dann her überhaupt.
Ich sage ja es gibt da unterschiedliche risiken so ne und jetzt sagt er melzer natürlich so so ein widerspruch in einer aussage muss natürlich irgendwie geklärt werden da muss muss nachgefragt werden.
Jetzt das sind die beiden aussagen dieser frauen ja also bei weitem ich meine offenbar hat er irgendwie eine tendenz dazu das kondome kaputtgehen es kann auch sehr gut sein dass dass sie das hier irgendeine.
Komische absicht hinter sich befindet wobei in diesem ersten fall.
Es wohl auch so ist dass er dass sie quasi dass sich das kondom kaputt gegangen sondern er hat ja einfach weggelassen.
So jetzt,
wie agiert nun die polizei denn da fängt es ja eigentlich an interessant zu werden da beginnt der teil der der für uns irgendwie undurchsichtiger ist und wo man irgendwie auch,
ein vertrauen in die institution hat wenn du mit der anzeige eines sexualstrafdelikten irgendwie zur polizei gestern erwartest du dass sie das nach,
den regeln ihrer kunst und ihrer ihren regeln halt irgendwie und ihren sorgfalt regeln irgendwie behandeln.
So was machen die ja die stellen erstmal fest dass die erste aussage die war ja die hat sie ja nicht unterschrieben ja das ist also der irgendetwas gesagt hat das aber nicht unterschrieben jetzt wird.
Die ursprüngliche aussage umgeschrieben die wird revidiert und zwar.
Dahingehend dass es zu mehrmaligen geschlechtsverkehr gekommen sein einvernehmlich mit kondom am morgen danach hätte er aber dann wäre ohne kondom irgendwie sie eingedrungen sie hatte gefragt trägst du eins er hat gesagt nein sie sagt müsstest du aber,
du sollst du sollst besser kein haben oder sowas ja aber sie lässt ihn gewähren diese aussage wird also umgeschrieben.
Nicht von der von der frau unterschrieben und das ist aber dann basis für weitere ermittlungen.
Diese zweite frau kommt erst zehn tage später dorthin und wird.
Ein vernommen von dem polizisten der die anweisung gegeben hat die aussage der ersten frau umzuschreiben
so und das ist nicht normal ja wenn du bei der polizei eine aussage machst dann schreib dir die nicht nachher um und sagt ich habe hier meine stilistische änderung oder
plot twists oder sowas weißt du das ist irgendwie.
Der ist nicht vorgesehen.
Klingt das doch gleich viel dramatischer.
Und so entschuldigung jetzt kommt am dreißigsten august.
All diese sachen waren unmittelbar in den medien,
unmittelbar sofort überall ne das ist jetzt das wiederum ist vielleicht nicht allzu überraschend aber trotzdem auch nicht in ordnung dass natürlich hier die
die
keine geheimhaltung wirkt sondern dass das hier ist die alle augen die welt war die augen der welt waren auf wikileaks ohnehin wegen dieser veröffentlichung und auf diesem fall das ist alles rausgelegt deswegen kommt am dreißigsten august nicht die zweite frau sondern der assange.
Zehn tage später geht er zu der polizei selber hin und sagt ich möchte gerne aussagen ja und wird von diesem polizisten befragt der diese
anweisung gegeben hatte das umzuschreiben ja ich hatte gerade gesagt dass wir die frau gewesen nein assange kommt dahin
und er wird genau der polizist der die erste aussage der ersten frau schon umgeschrieben hat den befehl dazu gegeben hat befragt jetzt den assange und der song sagte ja pass auf wir unterhalten uns hier gerne.
Ich möchte auch gerne aussagen aber ich habe keine lust dass hier wieder in der presse zu lesen der journal der polizist sagt ja nee klar passiert nicht nochmal ne und am nächsten abend am selben abend steht wieder alles in der zeitung und.
Das ist jetzt julian assange situation zehn tage nach dieser nach der initialen aussage der ersten frau.
Jetzt sagen die ja okay hier gibt's jetzt ein ermittlungsverfahren wir halten dich aber jetzt erstmal nicht fest.
Wir sagen nur du sollst mal hier in der nähe bleiben wir melden uns bei dir don't call und dann muss er irgendwie im september.
Muss er zu einer konferenz nach berlin und fragt bei der staatsanwaltschaft an ob er denn das land verlassen dürfen.
Und die staatsanwaltschaft will ich schriftlich ein dass er schweden für eine kurzfristige abwesenheit verlassen darf und genau an dem tag.
An dem er schweden verlässt nicht klar ist ob kurzfristig wieder langfristig weil er eigentlich nur zu dieser konferenz nach berlin will.
Erlassen die ein haftbefehl gegen ihn der fliegt mit fliegt von stockholm nach berlin aus seinem eingecheckt in gepäck verschwinden.
Laptops auch frankfurt also die story die hat mir wirklich also man checkt kein laptop ein.
Man checkt erstmal grundsätzlich kein gepäck ein und erst recht nicht mit laptop und erst recht nicht mit mehreren laptops.
Ja ich denke mal so was weiß auch julian assange und das wird dann sicherlich war das dann so ein hunni pott um einfach mal zu gucken ob denn was abhanden kommt.
Also anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären ja weil
wenn du wenn du julian bist irgendwie mehrere explosive veröffentlichung hinter dir hast es klar ist dass du eine mission in deren wahrscheinlich noch einiges lauert dann kannst du nicht einfach einen computer einchecken.
Ja vor allem man kann,
man kann ihm da auch keine mangelnde paranoia vorlegen er hat ja früher in seinen hacker zeiten unter anderem software geschrieben um festplatten so zu verschlüsseln
dass wenn man sie sich anschaut erstmal gar nicht sieht dass sie irgendwie verschlüsselt sind sondern quasi andere daten.
Anbieten um erstmal den eindruck zu erwecken da wäre überhaupt gar nichts anderes und das ist so explizit genau für so eine situation gedacht und da kannst du mir nicht erzählen,
bist du dann sagst du oh ja,
ich werde ja nur gerade irgendwie für vergewaltigung befragt so muss schon fragen wenn ich das ausland darf sondern checke ich mal meine meine ganzen daten irgendwie ein und gibt in irgendwelchen honks am flughafen so also.
Ja vor allem zwanzig zehn das waren wahrscheinlich computer noch mit festplatten wobei nee da kann ja schon gehabt haben aber.
Die haben die aufgemacht und dann kommt ein bildschirm hoch wo draufstand anders kann ich mir das nicht vor.
Ich kann mir das auch nicht erklären aber das ändert natürlich nichts daran dass sie trotzdem dass die computer weggenommen wurden und keiner sagt keiner äußert sich dazu also auch schon sehr skurrilen.
So jetzt jetzt ist er also.
Mit diesem europäischen haftbefehl gesucht es geht irgendwie die die dinge gehen ihr lauf und er sagt immer.
Ich gehe nicht nach schweden solange ich keine zusicherung habe von schweden dass sie mich nicht an die usa ausliefern ja da auch das wurde sehr viel öffentlich vertikutiert und auch von uns,
immer wieder auch in der sendung aufgegriffen.
Weil die schweden haben ihm auf diese anforderungen geäußert es gibt ja gar kein auslieferungs gesucht der usa,
also wieso sollten wir dir hier irgendwas zu sichern willst du was willst du denn noch wo willst du denn noch alles nicht hin ausgeliefert werden du du spinnst doch wir ermitteln hier wegen.
Wegen dieser vergewaltigungs- vorwürfe und es gibt gar kein auslieferungs gesucht der usa und ich hab eigentlich auch gedacht so naja,
keine ahnung ich weiß ja nicht wie üblich das ist dass jemand sagt ich komme nur in euer land und redet nur mit der polizei unter folgendem bedingungen so jetzt betont der nils melzer ja das aber tatsächlich in der internationalen praxis total alltäglich,
ähm,
nimmst du irgendjemanden der vielleicht aus dem einen oder anderen land politisch geflohen ist vielleicht jetzt hier als journalist arbeitet und.
Sagen muss okay bevor ich in großbritannien wegen was weiß ich veröffentlichung von geheiminformationen aussage brauche ich eine zusage dass sie mich nicht,
was weiß ich nach syrien ausliefern oder sowas ja also melzer sagt das ist tatsächlich durchaus alltäglich und auch kein.
Ein besonderes besonders krasses keine besonders krasse anforderungen außerdem sagt der assange auch.
Ok wenn ihr mir nicht garantieren können dass ich nicht ausgeliefert werde dann könnt ihr mich jederzeit in london befragen,
oder also ihr wisst ja wo ich bin ja ich komme ja hin ich gehe ja hier nicht weg ich bin wirklich zu hause und wir können das auch gerne über videolink machen alles gar kein thema ja und das haben die.
Insgesamt in den sieben jahren,
dreißig mal oder so angeboten also dreißig mal jedes quartal haben die anwälte sich nach schweden gewendet haben gesagt hier übrigens wollen wir ja und die schweden haben immer gesagt ey seid ihr verrückt sowas lassen wir uns nicht gefallen,
und auch das habe ich gedacht ja gut kann ich auch verstehen wo kommen wir denn da hin weil.
Die regeln für eine befragung definiert ja die polizei so stellt sich aber raus es gibt einen kooperationsabkommen zwischen großbritannien und schweden das vorsieht dass für die einvernehmen von personen schwedische beamte nach england reisen
oder auch umgekehrt und dass man so etwas per video macht und noch dazu.
Das gibt es nicht nur auf dem papier sondern das wurde in dem gleichen zeitraum zwischen schweden und england in vierundvierzig anderen verfahren auch so gemacht.
Das ist schon krass oder.
Es ist relativ klares zeichen dafür dass einfach hier gar kein interesse daran war hier ihn irgendwie ordentlich zu befragen.
Und das finde ich aber übel weil dieses strafverfahren.
Hat gefälligst im interesse im interesse der beiden frauen zu sein die hier angeblich anschuldigungen gegen ihn erhoben haben.
Ja und.
Das ist aber sehr offensichtlich nicht der fall weil sie die man könnte das argument anbringen dass er hier die polizei nicht im interesse der.
Opfer dieser mutmaßlichen straftaten handelt und das tut sie sehr eindeutig nicht und sogar auch explizit nicht denn die ähm.
Personen die frauen sagen selber wir möchten nicht,
dass diese ermittlungen in der form geführt werden jetzt hat der staat ihnen aber ein rechtsverdrehte bestellt der ihnen sagt also einen anwalt der ihm sagt ja pass auf,
vergewaltigung ist aber ein offiziell delikt das heißt die strafrechtliche interpretation eurer erfahrung ist sache des staates und nicht ihre muss man vielleicht kurz erklären es gibt antrags delikte und offiziell delikte.
Bei kleineren straftaten wird die polizei nur dann tätig und nur im sinne der opfer tätig wenn die eine anzeige erstatten bei bestimmten,
straftaten wird die polizei aber von sich aus tätig beispielsweise mord ja du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie,
jemanden umbringen und dann sagen wo kein kläger da kein richter den mochte eh keiner ist er hat keine anzeige erstattet also dürft ihr auch nicht ermitteln also komme ich straffrei davon ja ähnlich eben auch die sexualstraftaten aber
du kannst natürlich nicht ich meine wenn die.
Ich denke in jeder rechtsthemen egal ob offiziell delikt oder antrags delikt oder sonst was ist relativ klar dass die aussage des opfers relativ entscheidend ist ja und wenn die.
Wenn die frauen sagen der hat uns nicht vergewaltigt dann.
Oder wir möchten nicht dass diese dass dieses verfahren weitergeführt wird dann sollte dem natürlich eine entsprechende bedeutung beigemessen werden.
Und diese sehr also melzer beschreibt dann in diesem interview was relativ lange ist.
Auch noch dass es eben eine weitere reihe an ungereimtheiten die hier gibt und an,
e-mails die sich irgendwie groß die sich zwischen großbritannien und schweden
ausgetauscht werden wo die schweden dann irgendwann sagen ey komm uns wird das jetzt hier langsam zur affig wir stellen das verfahren jetzt mal ein und dann die aus großbritannien irgendwie so eine e-mail zurück kommt jetzt kriegt bloß keine kalten füße oder so ja also wo wo das ist halt wirklich genau,
die verschwörung die man sich darunter vorstellt wenn man sich darunter eine verschwörung vorstellt und dafür gibt's halt einfach eine ganze reihe von.
Krassen beweisen und das.
Das resultat davon ist eigentlich von dieser aktion von irgendwelchen schwedischen polizei leuten und diesen unterschiedlichen staatsanwältin die sich damit befasst haben.
Seit nunmehr zehn jahren bei neuneinhalb jahren schön assange eigentlich in der öffentlichkeit als ein vergewaltiger dasteht.
Und das zieht so ohne weiteres niemand in frage.
Oder das ziel eine ziehen schon leute in frage aber die werden dann auch nicht mehr ernst genommen und das ist schon ziemlich ziemlich.
Krass ne also was was da was da passiert ist und das erschüttert
tatsächlich mein empfinden in den rechtsstaat enorm weil ich davon ausgehe
dass jeder derartige fall jeder fall der irgendwie wenn es um die unversehrtheit von menschen geht der polizei angetragen wird,
dass der nach bestem wissen und gewissen nach den regeln und allen regeln der kunst und allen finessen,
gleichermaßen ordentlich abgearbeitet wird und dieses vorgehen hatte offenbar.
Das ziel dieses ermittlungsverfahren so lange wie möglich hinzuhalten,
und so ergebnisoffen wie möglich zu halten ich glaube immer noch nicht auch wenn mälzer in diesem interview sehr ausführlich darstellt dass schweden,
sehr wohl gute möglichkeiten hatte ihn auszuliefern und dass auch wahrscheinlich ist dass es getan wäre ich glaube immer noch nicht das wäre julian assange wirklich nach schweden gegangen,
dass sie ihn wirklich ausgeliefert hätten aber wenn man sich anschaut ich meine,
wenn dein ziel ist wikileaks zu zerstören dann.
Das beste eigentlich das was dem assange jetzt passiert ist nämlich dass er über neun jahre einen vergewaltigungsvorwurf ausgesetzt ist man ihn einfach auch alle aller möglichkeiten beraubt sein.
Dieser sache irgendeine aufklärung zuzuführen,
und jedes mal wenn er wenn wenn darüber berichtet wird dass er da in ecuador in der botschaft hängt gesagt werden muss weil er sich ein strafverfahren in schweden entziehen will,
das ist tausend mal besser als den in die usa auszuliefern zumindest mittelfristig nachts nach jetzt irgendwie,
sieben jahren hatten sie dann offenbar genug von der sache haben gesagt okay haben wir genug erledigt.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich schon auch anmerken in der zwischenzeit hat auch seinen teil dazu beigetragen insbesondere diese ganzen veröffentlichungen der clinton mails und die pro trump.
Kommunikation.
Deprimierenden ja kommunikation es gab diese kontaktaufnahmen mit dem wie heißt der typ ohne hinterkopf roger moore nee das heißt ja.
Roger.
Dieser typ so ein kleiner der südost der tat kein hinterkopf ich glaube der heißt nur also.
Ist james bond darsteller.
Ja wie heißt der andere google mal mann ohne hinterkopf.
Meinst du diesen diesen trump vertrauten der jetzt gerade der jetzt gerade im knast gekommen ist.
Ich glaube nicht dass dein knast gekommen ist der der wurde auch angehört in im rahmen dieser maler michael moore sorry michael moore oder nee michael muss man will heißt er denn.
Nein ist der bin ich nur wissen wenn du meinst weh.
Also tim mälzer und michael moore.
Roger stone.
Roger stone genau genau es ist der das jetzt gucke ich mal ganz kurz oder es ist das.
Der war mit dieser furchtbaren sonnenbrille durch die gegend läuft dieser irgendwie festgenommen haben.
Ja der hat kein hinterkopf genau.
Darüber habe ich keine informationen.
Was meinst du wenn du den googles worum's nur bilder von vorne gibt.
Der ist zwei d.
Bist du so reingeredet aber sehr sparsam version.
Auf jeden fall genau also der ganze.
Super okay.
So dass das äh genau spielt in der reihe er spielt in der restzeit auch nochmal einige rollen die jetzt nicht unbedingt sympathie wieder gut gemacht haben um das geht es aber hier alles nicht.
Überhaupt nicht also da gehts nicht drum aber das hat jetzt unbedingt nicht unbedingt geholfen die reihen zu schließen in seinem bei seinen unterstützern oder seinen potenziellen unterstützern.
Ja da hat er auf jeden fall einiges an federn gelassen jetzt.
Auch logbuch netzpolitik berichtete ecuador regierung ändert sich usa stellen gute kooperationen möglichkeiten in,
in aussicht wie man das so macht haben sie ja mit mit der ukraine auch gemacht und.
Brasilien.
Genau und möchten jetzt ganz gerne den assange haben und der lenin.
In ecuador sagt ja gar kein problem den wichser will ich eh daraus haben holt ihn euch auch das total krass.
Die haben immer das asyl weggenommen und damit auch die staatsbürgerschaft und haben die briten in ihre botschaft gelassen um den herauszutragen ja,
darüber haben sie in fünfzehn minuten vorher informiert also hatte irgendwie fünfzehn minuten zeit sich mit seinem anwalt darauf vorzubereiten das verfahren selber also dann dann tragen sie daraus und,
er wird sofort vor gericht gezerrt oder umgehend vor gericht gezerrt wegen seines verstoßes gegen die auflagen der war ja eigentlich in so einer
irgendwo in großbritannien auf dem land stefan oder oder irgendwie so so wie ein shirt haben die ja relativ viele grafschafter da saß er auf ihn zum bauernhof und.
Jetzt steht er da vor gericht und es soll darüber beurteilt werden ob er jetzt eine haftstrafe bekommt für seinen verstoß gegen die.
Gegen diese auflagen die logbuch netzpolitik folge hat ja damals den titel einmal asyl und eine flex und die flex war der die elektronische fußfessel die er hatte daher dafür hätte er die gebraucht hat er die wahrscheinlich gebraucht so.
In diesem verfahren ja,
legt der anwalt von assange ein dickes dossier auf den tisch und sagt hier eine richterin die da vorne sitzt ist befangen weil ihr mann kommt in fünfunddreißig fällen.
In fünfunddreißig fällen wurde der von wikileaks exponiert ja der ehemann und die richter wischen das ohne bedenken und ohne jede prüfung vom tisch und sagen alles klar du wirst verurteilt noch dazu,
wird er ja glaube ich dann noch von den richtern sogar beschimpft oder.
Ja es wäre ja ein narziss und überhaupt und so geht es ja gar nicht also das scheint auch so im angelsächsischen,
richter kultur umfeld etwas gängiger zu sein das hört man auch aus den usa sowas wäre natürlich hier ein totaler skandal wobei ich mir manchmal auch nicht mehr so richtig sicher mit was hier jetzt noch ein skandal wäre oder nicht.
Das krasse ist das dinge sind immer nur einmal einen skandal ne und genau also jetzt wird er davon von einem,
von gefangenen eindeutig befangen richtern verurteilt und wartet jetzt eben gerade auf seinen auslieferungs verfahren an die usa so.
Eine ganze reihe an ganz eklatanten verstößen gegen,
die prinzipien die rechtsstaatlichen prinzipien gegen die menschenrechte und noch gar nicht darüber gesprochen haben wir jetzt über die auswirkungen die das auf ihn hat ja.
Da zitiere ich jetzt einfach mal den nils melzer aus diesem,
republik interview julian assange wurde von schweden england ecuador und den usa gezielt psychologisch gefoltert zuerst mit der art von zutiefst willkürlicher prozessführung die erfahrung die verfahrensführung von schweden,
mit aktiver beihilfe durch england war darauf ausgerichtet ihn unter druck zu setzen und in der botschaft festzusetzen
es ging schweden nie darum die wahrheit herauszufinden und diesen frauen zu helfen sondern darum assange in eine ecke zu drängen,
es handelt sich um den missbrauch von justiz verfahren um einen menschen in eine position zu bringen in der er sich nicht wehren kann dazu kamen die überwachungsmaßnahmen die beleidigungen.
Erniedrigungen und angriffe durch politiker dieser länder
bis hin zu todesdrohungen dieser konstante missbrauch staatlicher macht verursachte bei assange enorme stress und angstzustände und an mehrere messbare kognitive und neurologische schäden hinterlassen ich habe assange im mai zwanzig neunzehn in seiner zelle in london besucht,
mit zwei erfahrenen weltweit respektierten ärzten,
auf die forensische und psychiatrische untersuchung von folteropfer spezialisiert sind die diagnose der beiden ärzte war eindeutig julian assange
zeigte die typischen symptome psychologisch erfolg folter wenn er nicht bald in schutz genommen werde sei mit einer rapiden verschlechterung seines gesundheitszustandes zu rechnen bis hin
zur todesfolge so die diese.
Zustände hat er natürlich nicht erst in der britischen haft bekommen sondern auch schon in der ecuadorianischen botschaft erlitten und da äußern sich natürlich immer leute bis hin zu zu ja der ist ja freiwillig in diese botschaft gegangen hätte ja jeden tag da rausgehen können.
Tja hätte er halt nicht unbedingt.
Ja jetzt wo es ihnen hingebracht hätte so dass er das verhindern wollte ist nachvollziehbar.
Krasse sache so jetzt wurde neun jahre später.
Stellen die schweden auch da wird auch darüber berichtet das verfahren ein.
Und sagen.
Ja die aussage der frau sei zwar glaubwürdig aber es gibt keine beweise für eine straftat und das hatte die stockholmer staatsanwältin die erste die den fall behandelt hat zweitausendzehn bereits nach fünf tagen,
formuliert und dann gab es diese aussage die anweisung zur änderung der der aussagen ja also.
Haarsträubend ja und es ist wirklich einfach nur ekelhaft weil,
mit jedem solchen missbrauch der institutionen des rechtsstaats geht einher dass das vertrauen in den rechtsstaat schwindet und das ist.
Schlecht für uns alle.
Wenn wir misstrauen in die polizei misstrauen in die staatsanwaltschaft misstrauen in die gerichte haben und.
Anlass dazu geliefert bekommen ja das ist unabhängig davon um wen es da geht wir haben diese ganze relativ komplizierte konstruktion rechtsstaat
um genauso solcher willkür entgegenzuwirken und deswegen denke ich müsste das mit mit der schärfsten,
genauigkeit verfolgt und bestraft werden der melzer erzählt auch dass er,
in schweden halt den frank katalog dazu geschickt hat und gesagt hat hier hätte man gerne eure auskünfte dazu dann sagt normalerweise wenn er so ein.
Fragenkatalog sendet.
Kriegt der sehr ausführliche antworten und dann irgendwie geklärt wird hier und da haben wir den prozess gewahrt und das war das und hier und pipapo und die schweden sagen einfach nur so nee den wollen wir nicht beantworten ich meine der sonne,
berichterstatter für folter sagt ich hätte da mal ein paar fragen du sagst ah das ist schon.
Sagt er selber das ist ein schuldeingeständnis ja günther wallraff hat dann eine.
Kürzlich oder in kurzer folge darauf eine ein appell von hundertdreißig künstlern und personen des öffentlichen interesses veröffentlicht irgendwie so,
quasi sich gegen diese auslieferung von assange zu richten und für humane bedingungen.
Und ich denke mälzer hat einen sehr wichtigen satz in dem zusammenhang gesagt der so sinngemäß war,
es geht nicht darum ob der assange jetzt ein held ist oder ein engel.
Oder ob man das gut findet was er mit wikileaks gemacht hat oder nicht.
Weil es geht hier nicht um engel oder helden sondern um menschenrechte und diese menschenrechte von assange werden verletzt so das heißt das was da passiert schlecht zu finden.
Ist grundsätzlich was anderes.
Als eine bewertung von dem was was diese veröffentlichung angeht die ich übrigens auch gut heiße wo ich nur in der b-note abzüge gebe und.
Wie man jetzt zu anderen veröffentlichung von assad steht denn jetzt kommt der spannende teil mit dem auslieferungs gesucht der usa die usa sagen.
Ok wir haben den hier der hat versucht er der manning bei dem passwort knacken irgendwie zu helfen,
ob der das getan hat oder so ist übrigens überhaupt nicht überliefert weil
da steht nur drin dass er irgendwie also in den chat looks die sie da von ihrem rechner bekommen haben steht irgendwie nur drin von einer person von bei der sie vermuten dass es sich dabei handelt die einen account hat auf einem.
Auf einem sehr bekannten server ähm.
Dass sie sagen hast du mal das und das probiert ich muss mal gucken ob ich diese rainbow davids habe oder irgendwie sowas ja also es ist noch nicht mal dass er überhaupt dabei geholfen hätte geht dafür gibt's noch nicht mal einen beweis ja und da hätte er auch maximal höchstens fünf jahre für bekommen.
Deswegen wollen sie in dem wegen dieser konspirativ dran kriegen also verschwörung gegen die usa zu irgendwie veröffentlichung von geheimdiensten expedition an den feind und so weiter so,
und da schließt sich der kreis dass das was du in der erforschen nämlich im weiter zumindest im weiteren verlauf hier getan hat eben sehr wohl.
Journalistische aufarbeitung dieser veröffentlichung war und für diesen.
Fall ist es so dass hier ein.
Dass wir es hier eben mit einem journalisten zu tun haben dessen menschenrechte verletzt werden und ich kann gar nicht sagen wie.
Wie sehr mich das ärgert weil das eben so gerade also in jedem einzelnen fall jeder einzelne fall den ein rechtsstaat abhandelt hat er bitte nach,
peinlichst genau nach den regeln und nach der sorgfalt und sonst was zu abzuarbeiten damit wir alle das vertrauen in diesen scheiß rechtsstaat behalten können.
Und.
In zeiten wo die ehe der ein signifikater teil der gesellschaft wirklich abtrünnig wird weil die das vertrauen in das system verlieren ja und,
an willkür glauben und an ungerechtigkeiten und so da sind das in meinen augen,
was damit du den assange passiert ist sind schwere straftaten und schwere vergehen gegen.
Gegen den rechtsstaat und gegen die demokratie.
Ich glaube das sollten sehr sehr hohe strafen draufstehen ging also willkür solche solche willkür walten zu lassen da bin ich wirklich ganz unerbittlich.
Wie geht es weiter tja.
Die usa haben erstmal nur ein auslieferungs ersucht gestellt und dann,
auch darüber berichtete logbuch netzpolitik die begründung wollen sie,
nachreichen und das werden sie jetzt irgendwie bei tun im rahmen dieses auslieferungs verfahren denn es gibt,
ein paar prinzipien die bei so einer auslieferung zum zum einsatz kommen und zwar spezifisch beiderseitiges strafbarkeit also das was.
Wofür die amis ihn ausliefern ausgeliefert bekommen haben wollen muss auch in großbritannien strafbar sein.
Das heißt hier hat großbritannien ein hebel für bedingungen der auslieferung ja.
Also die können jetzt nicht irgendwie also es kann nicht sein was was nur in den usa strafbar wäre und das.
Andere ist die spezifiziere das heißt.
Das verfahren was danach erfolgen kann wird.
Nur das sein was da ist also sie können jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen ja ja ja liefert den mal bitte aus hier für die hilfe bei dem passwort knacken.
Das gibt maximal fünf jahre kein thema und sobald der dort ist sagen die sagen sie denn ach guck mal da stellt sich raus der hat ja auch noch hier.
Dieses oder jenes getan und jetzt verknacksen wir den dafür auch noch ja das.
Gibt also eigentlich zwei hebel so sagt das auch der nils melzer des großbritannien.
Ja eigentlich hier milde und und und rationalität walten lassen sollte.
Gleichzeitig sagte aber auch es wird kein rechtsstaat er wird kein rechtsstaatliches verfahren bekommen auch deswegen darf er nicht ausgeliefert werden assange wird vor ein geschworenengericht in alexandria virginia kommt zu den berüchtigten,
vor dem vor dem berüchtigten cord wo die usa alle national security fälle führen so,
interessant wie kommen die auf einmal auf alexandria virginia der ort ist kein zufall denn die geschworenen müssen jeweils proportional zur lokalen bevölkerung ausgewählt werden.
Und in alexandria arbeiten fünfundachtzig prozent der einwohner bei der national security international community security community also ist sie,
verteidigungsministerium oder außenministerium so und die restlichen fünfzehn prozent leben davon den brötchen oder autoreifen zu verkaufen.
Wenn sie vor so einer jury wegen verletzung der nationalen sicherheit angeklagt werden dann ist das urteil schon von anfang an klar das verfahren wird immer,
von derselben einzeln richterin geführt hinter verschlossenen türen und aufgrund geheimer beweismittel niemand würde wurde dort,
in einem solchen fall jeweils freigesprochen die meisten angeklagten machen daher einen deal indem sie sich zumindest teilweise schuldig bekennen und dafür eine mildere strafe bekommen alter vater.
Das sind alles besser wenn du sowas liest das glaubst du ja gar nicht dass es das ist das ist unvorstellbar dass es etwas gibt.
Ja gibt's aber und.
Hier darf es aber nicht geben.
Ja darfst du gibst nicht geben gibt's aber und wir müssen uns halt sozusagen auch ein bisschen aus diesem wunderland verabschieden,
dass wir uns immer vorgestellt haben des umfangreichen rechtsstaates ich meine da hatten wir ja nun auch,
schon in deutschland genug beispiele ich erinnere nur an unsere sendung wie das da in hamburg abgelaufen ist und wieder auch auf eine ähnliche art und weise mit der öffentlichen,
meinung gespielt wurde und verhaftung und anklagen vorgenommen worden die weitgehend haltlos waren also diese erosion die wir beklagt.
Findet überall statt das ist jetzt auch noch skandinavien erwischt hat finde ich noch mal ein bisschen
besonders bedenklich bei großbritannien hatte ich eigentlich relativ wenig hoffnung und das wird sich jetzt auch in den nächsten jahren leider nicht verbessern unter dem neuen regime was da jetzt gerade am start ist,
ja und leider ist julian assange da wirklich zur unzeit in die speichen dieses systems geraten und es macht gerade nicht so den eindruck als ob er besonders viele chancen hätten da wieder rauszukommen.
Ja umso wichtiger denke ich ist jetzt hier die aufmerksamkeit der weltöffentlichkeit um ja dem in irgendeiner form entgegenzuwirken also in der auslieferung an den usa ja.
Und noch wichtiger als die weltöffentlichkeit die öffentlichkeit der logbuch netzpolitik hörerinnen und hörer.
Die sowieso.
Also unterschreibt betont was auch immer man da jetzt machen kann ich kann nur nochmal betonen es ist,
schwierig nach so vielen jahren der falschen beschuldigung die eben auch natürlich sich eben wie so einen nagel zweifel.
In das gewissen setzen oder in den hinterkopf setzen und auch dieser ganzen trump scheiße zu sagen ok jetzt stehe ich hier noch für diese menschenrechte ein aber wer irgendwo irgendjemand was von menschenrechten erzählen,
möchte muss eben auch davon ausgehen dass sie für alle gelten sonst,
sind jetzt eben doch wieder nur irgendwelche privilegierten rechte und gerade also eigentlich alle rechte die wir irgendwie menschen einräumen räumen wir nur,
für die fälle ein in denen wir vielleicht freiwillig nicht mehr ganz so gerne bereit sind die zuzugestehen dafür gibt es rechte ja alles andere wenn das,
alles andere sind privilegien freundschaften und gefallen.
Jut ich denke damit ist jetzt erstmal alles gesagt zu dem fall oder.
Ja ende ende februar geht's glaube ich los mit dem auslieferungs verfahren und ich hoffe mal wie.
Dass das dann irgendwie sehr kritisch und auch mal wieder ja gerade auch medial mal wieder vernünftiger behandelt wird ich würde ich würde noch eine sache noch,
sagen wenn es um solche vorwürfe von sexualisierter gewalt geht ist natürlich auch.
Das eignet sich sehr sehr gut um um leute irgendwie in ein in ein bestimmtes licht zu rücken weil sich,
kaum jemand traut im interesse von menschen die derartige beschuldigung vor sich haben.
Sich einzusetzen also kein thema eignet sich besser für,
das beschneiden von menschenrechten oder rechts einschränkungen von leuten oder für unsaubere rechtsstaatliche verfahren als irgendwie der vorwurf von sexualisierter gewalt stichwort hier wenn er irgendwie nach ostberlin rausfährst und guckst dir
an was da irgendwie an den ab brandenburg irgendwie auf den heckscheibe aufklebern klebt sowas ne wie todesstrafe für kinderschänder und so ne das ist ja das ist ja so ein sentiment was auch einfach in der bevölkerung drin ist deswegen eignen sich ja gerade
die derartige vorwürfe auch so sehr gut.
Dafür dass dann auch die presse vielleicht nicht mehr so genau hinschaut und deswegen hoffe ich sehr auf die mediale berichterstattung
zu diesem auslieferungs verfahren dass die da mal wirklich auch wieder ordentlich
sich mit auseinandersetzt weil ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen spezifisch diese beiden sachen das irgendwie in der gleichen zeit vierundvierzig verfahren per video link da befragung stattgefunden haben im gleichen zeitraum oder,
das ist völlig an der tagesordnung wäre solche zuordnung zum zusicherung zu machen dass man nicht ausliefert wenn jemand in irgendein verfahren außer das hab ich nirgendwo gelesen.
Das mag sein dass das irgendwo mal stand aber das ist doch der eigentliche skandal.
Ja oder dass dass diese aussagen so überhaupt nie getätigt worden sind von den beiden frauen also das geht ja einfach wirklich in den kern der berichterstattung.
So wollen wir mal in die usa schauen da was auch ganz unterhaltsam in den letzten tagen.
Insbesondere in,
ja das finden wir ja mal richtig gut denn dort fand statt die erste,
abstimmung über den künftigen kandidaten oder die künftige
kandidatin der demokraten im anstehenden rennen um die präsidentschaft ende dieses jahres
und das ist ja dann so rein medial läuft das ja im prinzip schon seit,
gut einem jahr wo sich dann eben die ersten kandidaten aufgestellt haben teilweise die mit dem man gerechnet hat teilweise welche die noch niemand so richtig kannte und,
traditionell entscheidet sich dann in schon mal.
Wer wohl überhaupt chancen hat noch nicht unbedingt jetzt so die finale entscheidung allerdings war es oft so dass der gewinner,
in am ende auch die nase vorn hatte so war das mit barack obama und ich glaube mit kater und so weiter also das spielt schon eine rolle obwohl dieses abstimmungsverhalten dort,
ganz putzig ist ich habe da ehrlich gesagt durchaus meine.
Also partien dafür weil er wird nicht einfach nur so normal abgestimmt sondern es gibt dieses korken verfahren für das ist irgendwie so richtig keine gute deutsche übersetzung gibt,
was das bedeutet ist dass die abstimmung finden in so turnhallen statt leute versammeln sich dort,
und für jeden kandidaten wird dann in irgendeiner ecke des raums so ist dann genug ecken gibt für all die kandidaten das war dieses jahr ziemlich schwierig
ja wenn sie so grüppchen bildung betrieben das heißt man joint einem einem lager indem man da einfach sich hinstellt,
und dann sozusagen dabei ist es so was kann ich da gibt's doch bestimmt auch so hat so ein bisschen was von reise nach jerusalem wo alle irgendwie rumrennen und dann guckt man irgendwie mal am schluss und
diejenigen die dann sozusagen kein sitz bekommen das sind die die
mit ihrer gruppe es nicht schaffen mehr als fünfzehn prozent der anwesenden zu versammeln also wenn man irgendeine unterstützer gruppe unter dieses quorum fällt also relativ zu der anzahl der leute die überhaupt ist an dem ganzen spaß
teilnehmen dann wird diese gruppe aufgelöst der kandidat scheidet eben dort aus.
Und die anderen gruppen dürfen sich da sozusagen darum bewerben die leute die da eben noch in dieser vereinzelten gruppe herumstanden dass die sich vielleicht ihrem lager anschließend und da wird dann eben viel diskutiert über politik,
aber es wird auch kolportiert das manchmal auch die qualität der schokolade kekse die im angebot sind der jeweiligen gruppe ausschlaggebend sein können,
das weiß ich alles nicht ach ja weil mir gefällt es einfach weil es,
also ich habe mal generell 'ne menge übrig für wahlsysteme wo man so ein second boot hat,
also wo man sagen kann naja das ich war zwar eher ein freund von jemandem der hier irgendwie überhaupt nicht in lebenswert support bekommen kann aber ich möchte auch nicht dass meine stimme dann wegfällt.
Und das ist ja etwas was ich in diesem abstimmung system auch wiederfindet ja man kann jetzt viel drin kritisieren das ist halt nur für leute die gut laufen können und so weiter und alte leute gebrechliche.
Seid alte arbeitslose leute.
Warum überhaupt auch in england und in in in den usa wahlen dann immer so mitten in der woche stattfinden ja also warum das nicht etwas ist was was am sonntag stattfinden kann was bei uns ja irgendwie,
verständlich ist ne.
Willst du da irgendwie den den pöbel auf einmal stehen haben.
Ja ja.
Alter nein da musst du aufpassen da musst du da musste die schön die stehen alle schön am band und abends kriegen die schnaps klar.
So läuft das.
Ja genau also ich also ich ich teile deine sympathie dafür zu sagen man hat einen wahlverfahren wo man,
auch auf den ausgang der wahl einen einfluss hat unter der unter der bedingung dass jetzt die erste wahl nicht sich durchsetzt ne das ist ja das ist ja dass das für dich entscheidender so ein bisschen.
Ob ich jetzt dieses korken verfahren irgendwie noch zeitgemäß finde weiß ich nicht.
Ja ich finde dieses wort zeitgemäß bei so wahlen manchmal ein bisschen schwierig ja weil er es immer so ein bisschen intonisiert,
es gäbe jetzt irgendwie so ein klar akzeptiert,
weg wie man das machen soll und gerade bei den wahlsystem und da kommen wir jetzt im prinzip darauf ist ja ganze diese ganze debatte immer von diesem ja man muss ja auch modern sein durch wobei und dann geht's einem schnell dahin
leute der meinung sind man muss ja jetzt unbedingt noch mal computer mit reinbringen weil das macht man ja auch sonst überall und das ist ja auch modern und das wäre ja dann eben prinzipiell gut und wir haben ja nun unsere position zum thema wahlcomputer hier schon
mehrfach dargelegt in diesem fall kamen keine wahlcomputer in dem eigentlichen sinne zum einsatz als das jetzt hier mit
computern abgestimmt worden wäre das nicht aber wir erinnern uns an deinen schönen beitrag auch rund um die analyse der software pc wahl die ja in deutschland zum einsatz kamen in einigen gemeinden um die wahlergebnisse zu melden,
und dort habt ihr ja gravierende sicherheitslücken ausgemacht und eben moniert,
wenn auch nur die tabulator von dieser ergebnisse in irgendeiner form manipuliert wäre dass es ja dann zu einem großen vertrauensverlust und chaos kommen könnte wenn eben man in irgendeiner form zweifel anmelden könnte,
stellt sich raus in wo in den usa also in.
In hat man sich gedacht holt mein bier.
Genauso aber sowas von und dann gleich noch den nächsten schritt gegangen und haben das natürlich mit einer geilen app gemacht also immerhin nicht auf wenn du vom neunzig gestartet das kann man ja vielleicht schon mal zugute halten
sprich die leute die in den jeweiligen wahlkreisen dort zuständig waren für die übermittlung der ergebnisse,
und das war in diesem jahr wohl auch etwas komplizierter da eben nicht nur die endergebnisse übermittelt wurde sondern auf druck der kandidaten
jetzt auch beschlossen wurde dass auch die zwischenergebnisse
veröffentlicht werden also auch diese sich auflösen den gruppen und so weiter also diese ganze entwicklung die das vor ort genommen hat damit sie eben dort die trends besser und die wähler bewegung besser ablesen können,
sprich es gab dort einiges zu erfassen.
Und das ist auch alles ordentlich auf papier niedergeschrieben worden und überhaupt wird in diesem ganzen prozess des eigentlichen ergebnis jetzt so also die ergebnis findung überhaupt nicht angezweifelt aber die übermittlung ist vollkommen,
schief gegangen denn man hat sich hier,
price price für eine smartphonebasierte app lösung entschieden von einer firma mit dem schönen.
Passenden namen shadow ja was,
etwas shady das unternehmen zuerst wollten die demokraten auch überhaupt nicht sagen werde diese app herstellt und so weiter dieses typische was du nicht weiß macht die nicht heiß kommunikations methode ist ja auch wieder komplett nach hinten losgegangen.
Ja
dann wurden eben diese ergebnisse in diese app eingetragen und diese app sollte das dann eben übermitteln um eben schnell das ergebnis liefern zu können und es wurde dann aber wohl relativ schnell klar dass das was diese app dann übermittelt hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert also man,
passt sich schon so ein bisschen am kopf dass leute noch nicht mal in der lage sind eine app zu übermitteln wo man auf der einen seite zahlen eingibt und auf der anderen seite wenn diese zahlen an einer anderen stelle angezeigt
also das ist irgendwie so eine terminal funktion die im prinzip den siebziger jahren schon gelöst wurde aber offensichtlich scheint es heutzutage etwas schwierig zu sein,
und was war das ergebnis riesiger kandal riesige auf anregung naja man wusste.
Das ding ist alle haben sich darüber aufgeregt und alle haben halt irgendwie auch diese wahl ins zweifel gezogen obwohl halt die demokraten immer gesagt haben so nee nee nee ist alles schon ganz super wir haben das alles aufgeschrieben ist alles auf papier.
Was man ja sagen muss was ok ist also eigentlich ist nichts passiert aber trotzdem war der skandal extrem hoch und da.
Also ich kenne ich.
Ist das problem.
Die haben tagelang noch gebraucht bis sie diese wahl diese ergebnisse zusammenhalten das erinnert so ein bisschen das war in hessen ja dann auch glaube ich ne letztes oder vorletztes jahr wo dann
wohin auch das c wahl abgeraucht ist oder nee die die durften c war nicht mehr genutzt weil wir das kaputt gemacht haben.
Haben sie etwas neues gemacht oder so und dann haben sie gesagt ja okay wenn es nicht funktioniert muss er halt diese nummer hier anrufen ja ja der fünfzig fünfzig orten nicht funktioniert fünfzig heute diese nummer angerufen
und so etwas hat hier jetzt in in auch die rolle gespielt aber ja man kann sich jetzt sehr schön anschauen welche.
Ja dann doch auch verschwörungstheorien unsere sich darum ranken wer hat jetzt dieses ding gewonnen ist das jetzt hier der,
ich glaube dann war es am ende und jetzt wissen aber nicht wer den dritten und vierten platz hat wo mir da auch irgendwie unklar war jetzt müsste es aber doch irgendwie und inzwischen sind sie auch schon wieder in den nächsten,
in den nächsten bundesstaat am auszählen gewesen ja ja ein.
Ein vorhersehbarem theater aber sehr auffällig ist die demokraten du hast jetzt so so,
ohne die undifferenziert gesagt die demokraten die demokraten machen schon relativ klar die demokraten in dafür verantwortlich sich diesen misthaufen andrehen zu lassen.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher ob das.
Ja ja die demokratie party ist schuld ja ja doch doch doch doch das habe ich mir jetzt in den ganzen us podcasts ich höre ja hauptsächlich us podcast.
Aber ich glaube auch in die war da stand es auch zur diskussion mit dieser software zu arbeiten irgendwie sowas weil er auch so ein kork ist et cetera.
Könnte sich jetzt überlegen ob sie es noch machen wollt.
Ja das haben sie sich glaube ich auch schon überlegt und die antwort ist nein.
Ja lachen wir lachen wir schön über die wahlen in.
Ja weil da fühlt man sich so überlegen sowas würde bei uns ja niemals passieren.
Ist doch glaube ich auch ungefähr so ein müsste doch irgendwo man jetzt ich musste mal in der schule musste ich mal alle us-staaten eintragen in den.
West nennt man das.
Flyer state auch ne und mich interessiert aber eher wie viele ob das da wohnen auch nicht viele leute ne.
Das ist nicht groß.
Ja das ist noch mit west genau nördlich von missouri okay ähm die haben ja auch so starten.
Thüringen zum beispiel.
Ringen das land ohne prominent das kennst du nicht das kennst du dich jetzt aus thüringen.
Was ist das denn für ein lied ist das von ist das irgendwie union oder was.
Nein das ist das großartige thüringen lied das kennst du nicht.
Okay dann haben wir was für das auto.
Okay die die story ist glaube ich muss man gar nicht mehr in aller breite erzählen die hat jetzt beschäftigt ja wirklich seit längerer zeit jetzt hier die die nachrichten thüringen.
Ministerpräsident war bodo ramelow der,
insgesamt einen ziemlich guten ruf da allgemein genießt auch so unter den ministerpräsidenten ist von der linkspartei ist das einzige linkspartei regierte bundesland und ich,
denke da gab's jetzt keine oder das einzige einzelmeisterschaft event von der linken und da gibt's jetzt glaube ich nicht so,
große probleme mit dem der hatte ich glaube im voraus auf die wahlen war so ein bisschen so dass er das so ein bisschen überlegt hatte inwiefern er überhaupt noch als sich an die linke da bindet oder als als er selber auftritt relativ.
Beliebter ministerpräsident der ist aber jetzt nicht geschafft hat die absolute mehrheit zu bekommen und jetzt gab es gibt es bei diesem ministerpräsidenten wahlen immer mehrere wahlgange.
Und ich glaube beim ersten bei den ersten beiden wahlgang muss man glaube ich zwei drittel mehrheit haben und ab dem beim dritten wahlgang reicht dann die einfache mehrheit oder so und für den.
Die in den ersten beiden anläufen hat ramelow es nicht geschafft zu mist ministerpräsidenten gewählt zu werden.
Und es gab gegenkandidaten von afd und fdp.
Die cdu hat verzichtet.
Cdu hat keinen kandidaten aufgestellt und hat dann diesen.
Also fdp muss man noch dazu sagen die fdp hatte irgendwie dreißig stimmen mehr als sie brauchte um über die fünf prozent hürde zu kommen ja also eine partei,
die ganz ganz ganz ganz knapp überhaupt da sitzen durfte.
Stellt also jetzt hier so einen so einen kandidaten auf der ministerpräsident du fragst dich überhaupt warum
tun sie das und es wurden ja auch wurde den ja auch nahegelegt dass einfach mal sein zu lassen von mehreren leuten kommen wir nachher noch zu und jetzt passiert es so im dritten wahlgang.
Die fdp und die cdu wählen diesen fdp kandidaten.
Die spd und die linke wählen den linkspartei kandidaten.
Und die afd wählt den afd kandidaten so jetzt im dritten wahlgang entscheidet sich die afd völlig überraschend,
lass einfach mal den fdp jetzt wählen ja und der wird quasi gewählt ja der kriegt eine ausreichende mehrheit um gewählt zu werden in diesem dritten wahlgang.
Und in seiner gottgegebenen liberalen weisheit nimmt dieser vollidiot die wahl sogar auch noch an.
Du fragst dich ja ernsthaft ob der also auf der von allen guten geistern verlassen ist ich meine ich will jetzt nicht klingen wie,
gerhard schröder in der,
in der elefantenrunde aber üblicherweise einigt man sich schon darauf dass einfach die partei mit den meisten oder die fraktion mit den meisten
wählerstimmen oder mit dem größten anteil auch den ministerpräsidenten stellt und sei es in einer in irgendeiner form minderheit geduldeten regierung.
Großes theater weil.
Wird dazu eigentlich nur sagen ich habe den eindruck dass diese war diese debatte falsch geführt wurde dieser kämmerling oder wie der heißt also ich werde mir den namen gar nicht merken dass ich mir merke ist dass er.
Ich nenne ihn immer ich nenne sie immer kümmerliche.
Der kümmert sich genau der kümmerliche.
Nimmt ernsthaft noch die wahl an da merkst du mal wie besoffen der typ gewesen sein muss und das würde ich jetzt nur erstmal sagen weil er.
Sich überhaupt zur wahl gestellt hat und meint als fünf prozent partei irgendwie die regierungs überhaupt stellen zu können ja.
Dass das dass allein das hätte ihm schon irgendwie zu denken geben müssen nimmt die wahl an und tritt dann auch erstmal nicht zurück ja dann diskutieren jetzt alle erstmal darüber ja mit den stimmen der fdp der der afd.
Kann man sich nicht wählen lassen und werfen der fdp vor gemeinsame sache mit der afd gemacht zu haben ja stimmt.
Man man macht das nicht,
und die fdp behaupten aber ja das hätten sie ja nicht gewusst dass die afd das machen wurde stellt sich raus lüge denn genau davor wurde gewarnt ja,
alle haben gesagt macht das nicht stellt kein kandidaten auf dann wählt die afd ideen,
und dann stehen wir auf einmal blöd da also es gab eindeutig warnungen und jeder der irgendwie zwei und drei zusammenziehen kann kann sich das ja wirklich auch.
Denken dass die afd das machen würde und zwar aus dem einzigen grund heraus nicht weil sie weil sie ernsthaft den als ministerpräsidenten sehen wollen sondern weil sie schaffen damit diese ganze diese ganze parlament wie ein tollhaus aussehen zu lassen.
Ja und genau das genau das ist geschehen es gab eine große debatte darüber dass die dass man sich nicht von der afd wählen lassen soll ja jetzt hat der kümmerliche irgendwie sein.
Seinen rücktritt
angekündigt ist aber glaube ich noch nicht zurückgetreten ich vermute dass der irgendwo noch ich habe ich habe das nicht rausgesucht aber ich vermute dass irgendwo als ein rekordhalter gibt für die kürzeste zeit
im amt als ministerpräsident und er will noch einen tag länger haben damit er wenigstens nicht in der fußnote der geschichte landet aber das ist nur eine theorie.
Jetzt wird sich natürlich zeigen was passiert jetzt als nächstes ja weil wenn du jetzt wieder wählen und die afd sagt alles klar dann werden wir bodo ramelow.
Dann kann der bodo ramelow die wahl nicht annehmen weil er ja von der afd gewählt wurde.
Kurze korrektur er ist zurückgetreten nach drei tage.
Ist er inzwischen gut.
Ja also er bekleidet das amt jetzt nur noch geschäftsführend zurückgetreten ist er aber aber das ändert natürlich jetzt erstmal nichts an dieser führungsloses zeit die das bundesland im prinzip hat.
Und zu allem überfluss also so viel dazu ich meine gut fdp ich meine eine partei aus karrieristen macht nicht greift natürlich eine karrierechance beim schopf wenn sie sich ihr bietet.
Erstaunlich ist,
was das dann im weiteren verlauf noch für ein ergebnis hatte nämlich annegret kramp-karrenbauer,
tritt vor die presse und sagt hier ich bin feste vertreterin der von allen seiten kritisierten und.
Widersprochen und widerlegt den hufeisentheorie das nämlich rechts die afd und links die linkspartei genauso schlimm sind und man mit beiden unter keinen umständen zusammenarbeiten darf ich habe aber außerdem.
Dringend auf die fdp versucht einzuwirken dass sie dass sie nicht in dieses offene messer reinrennen was die afd da hingehalten hat.
Und.
Jetzt konnte ich mich aber nicht durchsetzen und deswegen trete ich zurück ich will nicht mehr kanzlerin werden und ich will auch den parteivorsitz abgeben.
Krass oder.
Ja gut ich meine das muss man ja noch zugute halten dass sie das jetzt erkannt hat dass sie ihren laden überhaupt nicht mehr im griff hat weil das hätte sie im prinzip genauso vermeiden können wie die fdp auch dass der lindner noch nicht zurückgetreten ist sagt natürlich auch einiges aus.
Der lindner der hat das vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen.
Die fdp wird seit ich hatte das recherchiert ich glaube seit zweitausenddreizehn hat die fdp ohne nennenswerten widerstand lässt sie sich das gefallen dass lindner parteivorsitzender ist.
Sie haben ihm sogar noch das vertrauen ausgesprochen.
Na ja ich meine wir haben ja sonst niemanden der diese rolle bekleiden könnte.
Wie heißt die fdp.
Also ich meine die fdp setzt doch jetzt eigentlich nur das um was sie mit ihrem projekt achtzehn angekündigt hat.
Wir stellen jetzt bloß fest dass die achtzehn nicht für achtzehn prozent stand wie sie immer gesagt haben.
Sondern für buchstaben.
Genau.
Also dieser dieser akk rücktritt ist ein ist schon ein ein riesiges also ich sag mal so.
Die.
War hat sich relativ schnell als eine fehlbesetzung für diese rolle entpuppt ja wenn wir uns anschauen irgendwie ihre versuche da irgendwie lustig zu sein mit dem mit dem,
sitz mit dem witz über sitz toiletten da den sie beim karneval gemacht hat oder auch ihre.
Reaktion da auf den risa und so das waren alles relativ schwache leistung so kannst du nicht die cdu führen aber man muss auch sagen.
Der hat glaube ich das spielt ja schon auch eine rolle.
Ob du du kannst so einen laden nur so lange führen wie das genug leute überhaupt wollen und ich habe ehrlich gesagt den eindruck dass die die annegret kramp-karrenbauer,
sehr eindeutig innerhalb der cdu einfach haben auflaufen lassen die haben sich einfach gesagt komm ey,
diese.
Das war jetzt einfach auflaufen fertig wir haben noch zeit wir haben vier jahre zeit bis letztendlich bis die bis die kanzlerschaft oder oder drei jahre oder so bis die frage der kanzlerschaft wirklich geklärt werden muss kannst du,
die kanzlerkandidatur.
Der cdu jetzt hat sich die akk durchgesetzt lasst sie mal einfach ordentlich auflaufen die kriegen wir schon zerrieben ist eine kleine frau wir alten männer wir kriegen halt hier schon geklärt
ich hatte nicht den eindruck dass die irgendwann zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt die cdu im griff hatte.
Das was dran und man muss vor allem sehen dass halt so eine wahl von unten wie sie das eben bei der cdu gemacht haben oder zumindest simuliert haben,
dann eben nicht zu einem ergebnis führt das dann von den führungsebenen und delegierten ebenen auch entsprechend.
Unterstützt wird und die wahl war ja nun wirklich auch ausgesprochen knapp also das ist so ein bisschen auch so dieses brexit dilemma das,
wird denn jetzt wenn sie sich halt für ein konservativeren kandidaten entscheiden wonach bisschen riecht natürlich dann auch in der auch die die den den linken flügel wahrscheinlich der cdu auch gibt entsprechend verstören.
Ja krasse irgendwie eine krasse geschichte und es ist zeigt tatsächlich wie wie idiotisch diese parteien.
Im umgang sind mit destruktiven verhalten ja also sich so wieder in thüringen geschehen sich so vorführen zu lassen ja und mit noch ungewissem ausgang also ich bin mal gespannt ob das jetzt in in in den zweiten anlauf.
Zur wahl eines ministerpräsidenten für das land thüringen.
Besser läuft denn ja die cdu will natürlich jetzt alles tun um um eine neu um neuwahlen zu verhindern weil da stürmen die auf einmal blöd da weil,
gewissermaßen kriegt die fdp ja auch ein bisschen,
bisschen viel auf den sack dafür dass sie so also die cdu wird ja relativ verschont aber die haben das ja genauso die hätten ja genauso einfach hingehen können und sagen können alles klar dann wählen wir jetzt halt mit so vielen leuten,
wie war irgendwie wie es braucht widerwillig den ramelow ins amt und bannen diese.
Diese afd afd fdp gewalt gefahr da irgendwie die haben sich alle ziemlich bescheuert verhalten und es ist wirklich.
Eigentlich.
Ja ich will fast sagen bedauerlich aber vielleicht auch auf eine weise schön oder beruhigend zu sehen wie.
Ungeübt die im umgang mit destruktiven kräften sind weil das heißt dass es eigentlich nicht so wirklich welche gegeben hat bisher sonst wüssten sie eher wie sie mit so einer afd umgehen müssen.
Ja also die ganze nummer ist einfach zutiefst verlogen so als ich meine gerade die cdu die sich da einfach,
aufstellt so als wären sie so die hüter des rechtsstaats und überhaupt und die linken werden ja jetzt also immer noch dieses märchen von der sed-nachfolgerpartei,
sind sie ja bloß wenn man den maßstab anlegt dann ist die cdu eine cdu nachfolgepartei,
die damals irgendwie als blockflöte diesen sed-staat genauso mit gestützt hat wie alle anderen offiziellen splittergruppen die da eigentlich nur auf dem papier existierten umso pluralität vorzugaukeln,
last heimatcheck gab's glaube ich dann auch mehr stasi leute die im campus der cdu thüringen nachgewiesen worden,
als bei den anderen parteien also das.
Da kann man irgendwie glaube ich draufhalten egal wo man hin zieht man trifft die richtigen und der ganze laden ist halt einfach moralisch komplett bankrott nach dieser nummer.
Also
ich frage mich halt auch wie eine minderheitsregierung jetzt noch laufen kann weil klar wird die cdu sagen nö bloß keine neuwahlen weil dann verlieren wir zehn prozent nach den aktuellen umfragen und dann sind wir hier irgendwie komplett weg
vom fenster und mal von vierzig prozent auf irgendwie fünfzehn prozent
runter gedampft worden die fdp wird wahrscheinlich komplett rausfliegen also die werden sich sozusagen dieser neuwahl geschichte tunlichst entziehen wollen.
Und von daher wird der.
Die flucht nach vorn sein dann den ramelow einfach trotzdem zu wählen weil sie es einfach gar keine andere option mehr haben der hat aber dann immer noch das problem dass er eben eine minderheitsregierung hat und schwierigkeiten haben wird mit,
diesen parteien in dem zustand in dem sie sich da in thüringen befinden in irgendeiner form der arbeitsblatt zu schaffen und.
Notar zu dieser nachfolger geschichte der ramelow ist ein wessi.
Ja ja das kommt noch dazu.
Sie hätten die ruhig wählen können.
Ja und vor allem ist ja jetzt nicht so dass das dass der jetzt irgendwie diesen diesen diesen dunkel hätte irgendwie deine kommunistische revolution auszurufen so also das ist einfach wirklich komplett albern und an der stelle macht sich die cdu auch wirklich was vor,
das ist einfach diese abgrenzung debatte also ihm gelingt.
Sie haben einfach weniger argumente für diese diese abgrenzung nach links in die sie einfach enorm für energie stecken anstatt.
Energie mal in die abgrenzung nach rechts auch tatsächlich zu investieren wo sie einen eigenen parteitags beschluss haben dass das ja angeblich der fall sei.
Na ja also da können wir jetzt reden wir werden jetzt mal abwarten wie die geschichte weitergeht wie gesagt ich rechne jetzt erst mal wieder mit einer,
wiederholung der wahl zum ministerpräsidenten und mit entsprechenden wind für ramelow ob sich dann alle noch irgendwie ausreichend lieb haben,
habe ich so ein bisschen meine zweifel mir ist nicht ganz klar unter welchen rechtlichen voraussetzungen eine tatsächliche neuwahl,
dann noch durchgeführt werden könnte dazu müsste es ja eine auflösung des landtags haben dazu müssten eben zwei drittel dafür stimmen und deshalb bei den aktuellen,
mehrheitsverhältnissen zurecht nicht vorstellbar dass es stattfinden wird.
Obwohl die afd vielleicht dafür stimmt weil die sich am ende noch ausrechnet noch den ein oder anderen sitz dazu zu bekommen weil sie natürlich in ihrer zielgruppe
genau das geliefert haben was die leute mehr oder weniger von ihnen erwarten nämlich den laden vorzuführen und
diese these zu unterstreichen mit diesen jahr alle total unfähig und wir sind ja irgendwie die einzigen die irgendwie noch klar durchblicken und,
wir machen jetzt hier ordentlich rabatz halt diese dieser trump
mit dem die afd natürlich auch hausieren geht und den halt leider viel zu viele leute auf den leim gehen weil sie der meinung dass wir jetzt irgendwie eine coole sache und das wird uns in irgendeiner form nach vorne bringen bringt uns natürlich null nach vorne und man sieht ja auch schon
wohin die reise führen würde wenn die afd auch nur in die nähe eines machtstruktur geraten würde jetzt.
Wollte sie irgendwie strafantrag stellen gegen die chefin der der linken die susanne,
henning welslau dir für meinen geschmack den den tv- moment,
des jahres schon geliefert hat als in diesem kümmerliche in der,
im nachgang zur wahl diesen,
blumenstrauß einfach vor die füße geworfen hat das also das das fand ich einfach das geilste.
Signal was man überhaupt liefern kann und dafür werde ich sie feiern.
Der kümmerliche hat einfach also sowas von.
Also sowas von kein politisches gespür vielleicht nur der vollständigkeit halber wenn man noch gesagt ne wenn du also,
warum ist das so ein problem sich von der afd dahin wählen zu lassen na ja weil das heißt das ist deine mehrheit die dich da im amt hält und das heißt,
wenn du das eingehst dich von denen wählen zu lassen das jetzt jetzt ist die wahl hinter uns jetzt mache ich aber weiter irgendwie späßchen gegen euch dann hast du da keine chance lange zeit weiter zu regieren ja du wirst ja
spätestens dann wenn ein kabinett bilden musst und so.
Die darüber gedanken machen wie du das besetzt und da sind die da haben natürlich die parteien die mit dir koalieren oder die sich da dulden oder dich da irgendwie hin gewählt haben die stellen dann ansprüche,
ja also der kümmerliche weiß offenbar überhaupt nicht in welchem laden er da gelandet ist und wieder läuft na ja egal.
Ich würde sagen wir ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie das was passiert ich wette als nächstes wird die afd den ramelow und lässt sich lässt sich dann mal erklären wie der das macht.
So reden wir über moderne kunden verhältnisse.
Hallo,
also das ist etwas was ich tatsächlich seit seit einiger zeit sehr interessiert beobachte ist beobachtet also sieht man in vielen bereichen wie sage ich mal das ziel,
des verhältnisses zwischen herstellern oder also zwischen unternehmen und kunden.
Kundinnen ist auf so.
Subskription modelle zu kommen also statt dir etwas einmal für einen wert den es hat oder der dafür festgelegt wurde zu verkaufen ähm lieber ein abonnement anzudrehen also statt dir,
über den,
apple store für fünf euro einen film zu verkaufen lieber für einen zehner im monat ein netflix-amt statt dir statt dass du dir ein auto kaufst,
liest du das ja irgendwelche handys werden.
In abo-modell mit irgendwelchen alle zwei jahre ein top handyverträge und so weiter verkauft oder.
Die ganzen kundenbindung geschichten apps die irgendwie sagen ja hier ich bin der subskription also wir entwickeln uns mit mit vielem.
In die richtung dieses subskription modell was für die.
Hersteller oder software-hersteller jetzt erstmal um das darauf zu konzentrieren den vorteil hat dass du ein dauerhaftes einkommen hast ne also es ist ja auch bei
wenn sich beispielsweise jemand entscheidet logbuch netzpolitik zu unterstützen ist das total cool,
wenn da eine einmalige großspender auftauchen aber so insgesamt gut,
sind regelmäßige großspender.
Konstante permanente sich wiederholende groß spenden.
Wir sehen ja auch alle ne wenn du wenn du dir denkst ach okay netflix,
einen zehner im monat oder was was das euro im monat das ist eine sache aber wenn du dann eigentlich überlegst es seit hundertzwanzig euro im jahr für den scheiß ausgibt dann denkst du mich eigentlich dass du das eigentlich nicht bezahlt hättest also vieles geht auf so,
kundenbindung subskription und sonstiges mit erde hin und das ist eine besondere bedrohung.
Für die kfz- industrie die ja irgendwie davon lebt von diesem alten nimbus mein auto mit dem fahr ich irgendwie,
wo ich hin will und das meint hab ich bezahlt und sonstiges ne wir haben jetzt ja schon irgendwie inzwischen ihre eigenen banken und versuchen irgendwie die die karren zu finanzieren tun das aber in der regel glaube ich fast zu null prozent
weil sie weil das der einzige weg ist ihre karre noch an die leute zu bringen weil keiner mehr das geld hat um diese scheiß-teuren dinge zu kaufen.
So die nächste nachwachsende generation hat noch nicht mal mehr geld sich ein auto zu kaufen und vor allem auch gar keine lust mehr dazu weil die keine also keine veranlassung sehen k f zu kaufen und diese,
diese modelle der kundenbindung verfickten jetzt auch immer mehr.
Einzug bei den kfz- herstellern also die machen sich zum beispiel darüber gedanken darüber so etwas wie
wenn jetzt irgendwann mal die zukunft sein sollte dass alle nur noch mit irgendwelchen kategorie durch die gegend fahren
machen sie sich zum beispiel darüber gedanken na ja wie kann man denn da jetzt irgendwelche status level einführen wie was weiß ich die lufthansa das hat mit den
mit den flügen dass man sagt okay du bist aber jetzt hier ab so und so viel tausend meilen mit dem vw bist du denn jetzt irgendwie hier der bisschen vw zirkel oder solchen scherz ne überall so was machen sie sich gedanken.
Und das hat aber zur folge dass ich auch quasi dein dienstleistungsverhältnisse zu dem kfz- hersteller ändert,
und dafür gibt's jetzt ein sehr schönes beispiel was medial jetzt mal aufgearbeitet wurde von tesla und zwar ist es so,
ein bei tesla die haben ihren kompletten produktionsprozess im prinzip darauf ausgerichtet,
dass du features im nachhinein freischalten kannst und.
Dass beispielsweise dein auto da steht also ich nehme jetzt mal noch einen zwar noch ein beispiel was kfz- hersteller tatsächlich diskutieren.
Du kaufst dir einen kopf den vw golf ja.
Und dann sagt der golf dir irgendwann im winter so übrigens ist kalt du hast zwar damals nicht die sitzheizung gekauft aber du kannst ja das winterpaket buchen,
dann kostet sitzheizung einfach nur einen zehner im monat kannst du abonnieren witze sitzheizung abonnieren oder nicht wenn ihr hier klickst im im im app im appstore
dann machen wir die sitzheizung an ansonsten nicht
und das hätte tatsächlich für die autohersteller eine reihe an vorteil nämlich dass sie dir einfach das gleiche auto verkaufen können und die features einfach nachher freischalten und sich nicht diesen ganzen,
scheiß geben mit sehr individuell individualisierten kfz- herstellungsprozesses wo irgendetwas eingebaut wird und jetzt wird der knopf nicht reingesteckt und wenn du die klimaanlage nachrüsten willst bis zweitausend euro bezahlen also ich ein scheiß ja.
Sondern die liefern einfach jedem das gleiche auto aus
das auto hat internet eine kreditkarte ist eh an die karre gebucht und wenn du jetzt eine sitzheizung haben willst dann dann schaltest du dir eben frei zu dem preis der da steht und wenn gerade los wochos sind dann kostet eben weniger oder mehr ja
und genauso agiert tesla auch mit seinen kfz und,
gib dir sage ich mal die drei großen unterschiedlichen ausstattungsvarianten irgendwie nur ein motor,
zwei motoren und irgendwie enorm viel power ja aber was das auto sonst noch so an,
features hat oder so wird,
über das wird über die software geregelt zum beispiel haben die auch alle die gleiche batterie wir haben damals auch darüber berichtet dass tesla einem den fahrern von autos mit der kleineren,
reichweite in irgend so einem desaster mal für das wochenende die längere reichweite freigeschaltet.
Ja das war in florida als der hurricane dort ankam.
So klingt immer total geil sachen freischalten stellt sich raus kann man auch wieder abschalten,
hier gibts jetzt aktuell einen fall von tester der die aufmerksamkeit der öffentlichkeit bekommen hat der sich dann aber im weiteren verlauf wie sich herausstellte überhaupt kein,
einzelfall ist und zwar gibt es hier ein gebrauchtwagenhändler.
Der kauft einen tesla von tesla bei einer auktion wo die irgendwie rückläufer und irgendwie.
Reserve tesla und sowas die verkaufen ja und der gebrauchtwagenhändler kauft also von tesla einen tesla mit dem autopilot.
Der tesla steht da irgendwie eine zeit lang rum bei dem auf dem hof er macht mehrere testfahrten mit dem autopilot und eines tages kriegt ihr einen ein update hinweis der.
Autopilot wurde geupdatet,
und stellt fest dass er danach irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert zu dem zeitpunkt hat er aber schon irgendwie ein kaufvertrag mit einem neuen kunden dem er dann,
diesen tester überlässt und die sich beide darüber einig sind dass es ja hier irgendein problem mit einem update gegeben hat weil beide ja bei der testfahrt gesehen haben dass das auto diesen autopilot hat.
Und jetzt rollt der kunde also vom hof steht sein auto in der garage wundert sich dass es kriegt noch ein paar updates aber er kriegt seinen autopiloten nicht zurück jetzt ruft ja bei tesla an.
Und sagt ja hier mein autopilot und so tessa sagt ihm ja pass auf wir haben dein auto auditiert,
und haben festgestellt dass das ja jetzt irgendwie dir gehört und du für diese driving autopilot feature hast du nicht bezahlt deswegen schalten wir dir das wieder ab.
Und das ist natürlich echt 'ne starke sache weil die ja dann offensichtlich die ansicht vertreten,
dass du dieses ich glaube was kostet das irgendwie sechs bis achttausend euro oder so je nach modell.
Dass du dieses feature quasi als person an dich gebunden für dein auto kaufst und wenn du das auto abgibst tesla ein neue situation hat,
mit einem neuen tesla kunden dem dann dieses feature noch einmal verkauft werden kann,
was glaube ich sich mit der gängigen auffassung davon wie menschen autos kaufen oder auch zum beispiel in ein solches feature investieren,
und sich überlegen ob sie dieses geld ausgeben wenn sie das auto kaufen oder nicht relativ auf den kopf stellt man fragt sich natürlich auch,
reicht es dann vielleicht einmal zu bezahlen um das dauerhaft zu behalten also kann ich was weiß ich,
ein model s kaufen mit full full driving ja,
und wenn ich das zu schrott gefahren oder verkauft habe nehme ich meinen features set mit auf das nächste auto das kann ich mir nämlich nicht vorstellen das wäre die nächste erwartung die man dann hätte dass man sagt okay ich bin ein tesla kunde ich habe,
bei tesla und es könnte so sein dass man das quasi auch,
es ist keine subskription sondern es ist ja ein feature aber quasi dass sie sagen ja okay du hast das anlockt du hast du hast damals.
Du hast einmal achttausend euro für für autopilot bezahlt jetzt hast du in jedem tester den du kaufst autopilot.
Ja so als wenn ich apps kaufe im smartphone habe ich ein neues smartphone kann ich dieselben apps wieder die schon mal gekauft habe alle wieder installieren.
Es könnte also ich glaube das ist ein guter vergleich das scheint die auffassung von tesla zu sein,
diese features für ihre autos angeht weil klar wenn wenn ich dir ein iphone verkaufe gebe ich dir nicht die app verkaufe ich dir nicht die apps mitglieder drauf sind du hast ja dann deine eigenen.
Ich glaube aber nicht dass das klug wäre von tesla weil.
Sie damit ja den weiter verkaufswert ihre autos torpedieren würden und damit auch die bereitschaft der leute diese autos zu kaufen.
Ja total.
Auf jeden fall total vira kram und es klingt irgendwie jetzt erstmal wenn man's liest wie so ein ey das kann doch irgendwie alles gar nicht sein das müssten sie auf kulanz klären aber jetzt ploppen halt immer mehr fälle auf und auch dieser spezifische händler sagt dass er irgendwie,
seinem.
Wie groß nicht großvater wie heißt das wenn man heiratet schwiegervater selber schwiegervater ein einen anderen tesla verkauft hat mit dem luder chris mode und der war dann auch auf einmal weg.
Also ein.
Geht irgendwie wirklich überhaupt nicht also es ist.
Es ist völlig unklar ob das jetzt hier irgendwie alles nur eine große totale kommunikations katastrophe ist und alle anderen vorbei reden und irgendwelche handeln dabei,
tesla einfach gerade irgendwas total explodieren lassen andererseits ist der fall ja jetzt irgendwie aus ende dezember januar da ist das irgendwie passiert also ist jetzt nicht,
so mega brandneu aber die meldung ist jetzt vom siebten februar oder sowas,
also vielleicht tut sich da noch was weil das das wie du schon sagst also gerade der wiederverkaufswert ist wenn du mal auf einen tesla gebrauchtmarkt schaust da ist halt einfach autopilot steht im titel von nahezu allen fahrzeugen als feature,
wenn das jetzt hier sich so bewahrheiten sollte als als installationen realität dann heißt es ja einfach erstens,
du kaufst dir ein auto mit autopilot du hast dieses feature dann einfach nicht so ist es einfach quasi nicht dich das gilt dann auch im.
Die anderen machen das ja auch tim das ist ja genau der gag ob du den tesla mit orte pilot kaufst oder nicht du kriegst den gleichen tesla.
Es gibt nicht bei tesla eine fabrik wo rechts die mit autopilot und links die ohne autopilot runterrollen.
Es gibt nur ein software-update eine konfiguration für kunde kriegt den kunde kriegt ihr nicht.
Ja es ist ist es es ist insofern merkwürdig als das ja zum beispiel wenn du so ein model model x kaufst auch diesen lifetime kostenlos strom nachtanken ding auch noch dazu bekommst und das ist ja sehr wohl übertragbar,
also das geht irgendwie alles nicht so richtig zusammen und ist ja auch dann sozusagen für mich wenn ich jetzt mir wenn ich mich jetzt entscheiden würde oder,
jeder nicht nur ich ich kaufe mir jetzt einen tesla so autopilot hätte ich gerne erhöht ja den wert des wagens.
Was es dann ja nicht mehr tut das heißt dieses autopilot feature,
ist dann sozusagen nichts was ich weiterverkaufen kann und das senkt natürlich dann auch meine meine investitionsbereitschaft also es wird sozusagen dazu führen dass leute dieses feature nicht mehr kaufen weil sie es eben nicht weiter verkaufen können weil es dann halt in der hinsicht auch viel zu teuer ist.
Ja die könnten aber natürlich auch argumentieren naja tim du kaufst einmal autopiloten das hast du diese features hast du dein leben lang in jedem tesla und du wirst ja noch mehrere fahren in deinem leben also in dem leben wo du dir einen tesla kaufst.
Ist jetzt aber unsere annahme dass das vielleicht unter umständen so sein könnte und sehe ich jetzt noch nicht so richtig belegt.
Genau ich finde es auf jeden fall sehr skurril und das zeigt halt.
Erste schöne schritte in diese neue welt der subskription wo quasi die vorteile von wir können dinge in software klären.
Von den unternehmen auch mal genutzt werden denn tatsächlich ist es für tesla eben
also die idee überhaupt zu features ein- und ausschalten zu können an einem auto ist ja wirklich genial also du was meinst du was für eine komplexität,
vw jetzt beispielsweise in der lieferkette haben um die ganzen unterschiedlichen vws darunter rollen zu lassen
und stattdessen einfach immer den gleichen tesla zu bauen bis jetzt auf die massiven unterschiede mit zwei motoren oder so drin und wieder ding lackiert wurde,
und zu sagen okay wir können jetzt features nachrüsten das ist das wird den wahrscheinlich obwohl sie dann quasi.
Insgesamt jedes mal das teure auto bauen müssen werden sie am ende billiger im produktionsprozess haben weil die ganze komplexität wegschneiden können.
Und dann eben diese möglichkeit was weiß ich subskription oder guter kunde oder auch vor allem ein feature anfüttern zu können,
wenn du sagst witze sitzheizung haben und der kunde sagt nein brauche ich nicht dann machst du die halt mal an.
Wenn's kalt ist weißt du willst du nicht doch sieht's halt so ne.
Also das ist auf jeden fall auch ein ein fall für den verbraucherschutz also das das muss an der stelle aber auch wirklich mal ganz klar geklärt werden wie wie so ein modell ist und was hier kunden gebunden sein kann und was ihr fahrzeug gebunden ist weil es hat ja auch was mit erwartungshaltung zu tun.
Und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass tesla sagt ok pass auf ist auch in ordnung wir können dir alle wir können ja hier eine single user leisten wir können dir manfred crypton das können wir dir alles geben für den autopiloten du kannst ihn auch pro fahrt für einen zehner aktivieren,
so ist doch das pricing im softair-bereich jetzt auch
du kannst den lifetime lizenz zu holen du kannst eine manfred switchen holen du kannst eine fünf fünf einzelplatz lizenzen holen so
das wirst du im autobereich wahrscheinlich in ähnlicher form dann auch finden.
Ist natürlich blöd wenn du denn wenn du halt keinen ne wenn du wenn du halt dann auf einmal kein digitales erbe hast was ja das nächste ding ist ärztin tesla.
Was erstmal nochmal den autopiloten neu kaufen.
Oh je das ist echt eine schöne neue welt.
So was haben wir noch.
Völlig überraschend polizisten missbrauchen den zugang zu den datenbanken die sie haben ja doch.
Nein.
Doch doch doch doch doch in greifswald ja,
ermittlungen wegen verstoß gegen das datenschutzgesetz da gab's also irgendwie einen polizisten der hat ohne ermittlungs-und daten eingesehen in den polizeilichen datenbanken und der war in einer facebook-gruppe.
Die in der irgendwie afd sympathisieren äußerung und rechte positionen die ganze zeit ventilieren wurden und in dieser gruppe zirkulieren dann eben auch wohnadresse klarnamen und so weiter
von irgendwelchen leuten die die afd wohl missliebige findet ja,
in einem fall lag aber eine auskunft sperre vor und da hat er die daten deshalb nicht bekommen und es scheint das ja auch genau wegen dieser auskunft sperre überhaupt darauf gekommen sind dass ihr diese ganzen zugriffe macht.
So jetzt ist die frage was.
Was hat das für konsequenzen und welche konsequenzen sollte so etwas haben es gibt drei behörden die für die das eine rolle spielt erst mal die polizei selber,
also die polizei greifswald dann die staatsanwaltschaft stralsund und dann die datenschutzbehörde.
Des landes das ist wahrscheinlich mecklenburg-vorpommern so die lokale polizei sagt okay der polizist kriegt ein disziplinarverfahren und darf keine abfragen mehr stellen.
Die staatsanwaltschaft sagt naja das ist nicht strafrechtlich relevant.
Denn das ist uns irgendwie bekannt was da passiert ist aber,
irgendwie es gibt keinen zusammenhang hier zu den zwischen den auskünften und den aktuellen ermittlungen und wir werden das jetzt irgendwie.
Wenn es ist keine strafrechtliche sache das ist allenfalls ein verstoß gegen das datenschutzrecht.
Und das datenschutzrecht da kümmert sich der datenschutz rum also wird der daten der datenschutz des landes prüft jetzt irgendwie ob da gegebenenfalls eine ordnungswidrigkeit vorlag dass er auf diese daten zugegriffen hat.
Und das ist keine seltenheit,
es gibt in mecklenburg-vorpommern das ist ja sowieso nur durch zufall aufgefallen dass er diese unberechtigte zugriffe gemacht hat in hessen gibt es zum beispiel regelmäßige kontrollen wo,
stichprobenartig bei so ungefähr jeder zweihundert
eine abfrage die beamten nach dem grund für die abfrage gefragt werden und dann müssen sie,
wenn sie kein plausiblen grund angeben dann gehen gucken sich die datenschutzbeauftragten der polizei das an aber auch das heißt du hast eine wahrscheinlichkeit von null komma fünf prozent.
Dass du erwischt wirst und.
In einem halben jahr wurden in hessen trotz dieser geringen entdeckungswut neuntausend fälle an den datenschutzbeauftragten übergeben.
Das ist irgendwie die nehmen als beispiel da waren helene fischer konzert in frankfurt ja.
An dem abend wurden dreiundachtzig mal die daten von helene fischer durch polizeibeamte abgefragt nur in frankfurt.
Frankfurt weil die sich auffällig.
Die wollten halt die wollten personenschutz machen.
Ja sie hat sich auffällig benommen für unter umständen auf der bühne da müssen sie müssen wir vorher ermittlungen eingeleitet werden.
Also.
Die redet die ganze zeit von schöner welt und und und und so weiter und wie gut alles ist das können wir doch ganz anders.
Dass polizisten in diese datenbanken schauen ist tatsächlich absolut normal ja das ist auch meine.
Mein bevorzugter weg herauszufinden was da so über mich drin steht man fragt halt einfach polizisten sagt kannst du mal gucken und natürlich machen die das.
Teilweise greifen die polizisten privat auf die datenbank zu um irgendwie ihr zu gucken ob ihr nachbar in ordnung ist oder.
Irgendwie polizei polizisten hatten dienstlich erhobene handynummern benutzt um sich minderjährigen sexuell aufzudrängen
alles im bereich der ordnungswidrigkeiten lieber tim sind ja die polizei krass oder nee in dem fall.
Ja es ist wirklich krass wundert wundert sein auch irgendwie nicht das bei das bei polizisten immer dazu tendieren irgendwie auch ihren kompletten freundeskreis nur aus polizisten zu rekrutieren und das andere da irgendwie.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob die das freiwillig machen ob das notgedrungen ist ne.
Ja also ich meine vertrauen erweckt das jetzt nicht gerade unbedingt naja.
Nicht so schön.
Ja das ist genau der punkt warum man diese.
Diese datensammlung in den händen der polizei einfach wirklich nicht haben will das ist gang und gäbe dass das auf solche sachen zugegriffen wird und das wieder ebenso ein,
ne das will man wirklich nicht dass diese ganzen datenbanken sind frei zugang da brauchst dich auch nicht zu wundern dass irgendwie ne von allen möglichen.
Das auf allen möglichen todeslisten und wo auch immer der ganzen bis zirkuliert wieder alle möglichen melder andresen stehen.
Gut guck mal weiter.
Ja jetzt kommen wir weiter es geht weiter mit der plattform haftung ich habe mir gesagt plattform haftung ist das große thema dieser sendung.
Und zwar geht es jetzt um einen fall der schon auch größere wellen geschlagen hat und zwar so seid,
anfang januar ging das los und zwar geht es um spanner videos das ganze.
Erreichte so dass das licht der öffentlichkeit anfang januar durch die veröffentlichung einer dokumentation.
Der journalistin patricia schlosser das format ist steuerung so ich glaube von funk oder sowas produziertes ding was irgendwie auf youtube dann erstmal veröffentlicht wurde.
Und die hat sich.
Porno plattformen angeschaut in denen es die kategorie wo jörn gibt also eine kategorie in der.
Ihr habt irgendwelche beobachtungs und spanner videos veröffentlicht werden.
Irgendwas weiß ich irgendwelche leute aus der ferne bei irgendwas beobachtet oder auch irgendwelche versteckte kameras in irgendwelchen duschen oder so und in dieser doku stellt sich halt raus
dass das ein relativ großes,
relativ großer phänomenbereich ist also es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre diese kategorie als als hersteller ein mangel an videos.
Und dort findet die journalistin unter anderem neben vielen anderen videos auch einmal so ein.
Typen der irgendwie was weiß ich auf seiner eigenen toilette eine kamera angebracht hat und dann irgendwie seine bekanntschaften dort gefilmt hat und in der im rahmen der doku,
deckt sie auch noch auf wer das ist also sie entdeckt den findet irgendwie hinweise darauf wo der sich aufhält und wo diese videos gedreht wurden.
Und sie findet auch videos die in einem dixi gedreht wurden,
sind diese plastiktüte die immer neben den baustellen und auf musikfestivals bevorzugt stehen und die wir alle so kennen und lieben und,
da hat sie dann offenbar videos gefunden wo irgendwie in der toilette oder so am rand der toilette brille quasi eine kamera positioniert waren.
Die dann dort das geschehen gefilmt hat und offenbar hat da jemand diese kamera angebracht und.
Die videos nachher auf dieser porno plattform veröffentlicht,
tja ziemlich krasse geschichte und sie die dokumentation zeigt an wieso recherchiert und irgendwann die festivalbändchen anschaut die die leute tragen irgendwann den namen des festivals erkennt und dann,
noch im weiteren verlaufen von einer anderen journalistin der name ich gerade nicht parat habe erfährt dass der.
Dieser anbieter der videos ihr gesagt habe
dass er bei diesem festival arbeitet also hätte in irgendeinem privaten chat gesagt ja ja dieses jahr arbeite ich auch wieder dort und werde wieder eine kamera anbringen denn er hat das irgendwie zwanzig sechzehn und zwanzig achtzehn wohl getan.
Tja die.
Informiert dann die crew die dieses festival veranstaltet und auch dieser täter wird dann identifiziert.
So
es gibt jetzt eine längere auseinandersetzung damit wie diese festival veranstalter crew mit dem fall umgegangen ist
es war so das war ein sehr loses kollektiv was diese veranstaltung gemacht hat und wie das bei so losen kollektiven ist du hast halt ein problem oder unterschiedliche service level je nachdem,
welche ansprechpartnerin du durch zufall erlangst,
über dieses phänomen haben wir relativ lange gesprochen in der folge in der ich auch über,
hier hält c c d die schnittstelle und so gesprochen habe die folge würde ich in dem kontext auch ganz gerne nochmal empfehlen findet ihr in den shownotes ich weiß gerade nicht genau welche episode das.
So dass die videos werden irgendwie online offline genommen und ja.
Man kümmert sich also jetzt irgendwie man.
In den medien wird viel darüber gesprochen okay festival festival spanne aufnahmen bei festival und so wurde also behandelt.
Und dabei in meinen augen ein bisschen außen vor gelassen das ist das sehr.
Verbreitet gibt also diese wände wie gesagt wenn du diese kategorie gibst das ist nicht alles voll mit festival dixies sondern es ist voll mit irgendwelchen duschen privat duschen leute die,
beim sächsisch film wo du auch so naja sagen wir aus position der kamera erahnen kannst dass die jetzt,
eventuell irgendwo auf irgendeinem schrank oder so ist und wahrscheinlich versteckt oder so und da gibt es offenbar eine ganze szene ja und in dieser szene die interessiert sich offenbar auch für das geschehen in einem dixi was ich ehrlich gesagt mir nie hätte vorstellen können dass ich da irgendjemand für,
interessiert hat aber dann doch eine relativ große reichweite erlangt.
Die frage die ich mir stelle ist in welchem rechtlichen rahmen operieren eigentlich diese plattform.
Denn dass diese videos im zweifelsfall nicht konsensuell angefertigt wurden,
und es sich damit eben um straftaten handelt diese videos anzufertigen und diese videos zu veröffentlichen,
und diese videos zu verbreiten sollte eigentlich offensichtlich sein,
gerade wenn man sich so eine plattform anschaut die quasi diese kategorie gezielt anbietet,
auch im falle von x hamster natürlich damit geld verdient so hieß die plattform auf der diese videos entdeckt wurden dann fragt man sich natürlich schon,
wie reagieren die denn eigentlich auf so eine löschanlage frage tja ärgerlicherweise.
Durfte auch ich das dann relativ kurz danach lernen denn einige erinnern sich ja vielleicht noch dass ich im letzten jahr ein bisschen mit dem fusion festival,
die pressearbeit gemacht habe im rahmen des kampfes um die genehmigung des festivals und der,
komischen verschwörungen von irgendwelchen rechten polizisten mit afd vergangenheit die da darauf gezielt haben,
dieses festival irgendwie unter massiver polizeipräsenz zu stellen oder sogar nicht stattfinden zu lassen am siebenundzwanzigsten.
Januar.
Er fuhr dann der kultur kosmos veranstalter des fusion festivals durch anonyme e-mails dass auch auf dem fusion festival in einer dusche,
in einer gemeinschaftsdusche in so einer offenen dusche wo man sich frei stehen konnte menschen gefilmt wurden und die videos davon,
auf dieser plattform x hamster veröffentlicht wurden.
Menschen waren vom schulterbereich abwärts erkennbar und.
Der anbieter der dort irgendwie unter dem namen wahrscheinlich nicht so ein richtiger name,
hannes lange nutzername hannes hidden kämme diese bilder veröffentlicht hat hatte außerdem auch noch so privat videos ja also wo wir quasi man kann sich auf dieser plattform irgendwie folgen und privat videos teilen
und auch irgendwie passwort geschützte videos das scheint so ein bisschen der teil zu sein wo dann der,
wo sich diese spanner kennenlernen und diese zwei mal den
das richtige material tauschen auch in dieser dokumentation von patricia schlosser findet das so statt dass sie dann nämlich sah dass sie sagen ja okay wenn du den richtigen shit sehen willst dann musst du mir auch material schicken.
Und der,
täter mit dem sie da schreibt der sagt dann auch du kannst dir schon vorstellen dass ich hier nicht irgendwas meine sondern es muss schon auch ein echter schritt sein ja also nicht irgendwas was du aus dem internet runtergeladen hat das kann ich mir selber runterladen,
sie fertig dann auch tatsächlich so ein video an von sich selber ja im im rahmen ihrer recherche sowas schon auch eine
krasse sache ist und gewinnt dadurch aber eben auch das vertrauen dieses täters weil der sie eben dann für einen oder einen nähe von den ihren hält.
Das,
ist jetzt hier auch passiert also der täter der auf dem fusion festival auf der dusche gefilmt hat hat auch hier so private videos dann,
hochgeladen insgesamt waren das so wie wir das gesehen haben sechs öffentlich.
Und ein siebtes privat markierten für seine freundinnen.
Und ja der kulturen hat das umgehend dem anwalt übergeben der dann auch sofort unterlassung und löschung von der plattform gefordert hat und es war dann auch innerhalb weniger minuten,
offline jetzt habe ich aber in diesem rahmen kontakt bekommen mit stefan meiner.
Der für weiß in diesem kontext schon länger recherchiert und ein,
solche videos auch schon gemeldet hat und der jetzt berichtete mir sowas wie genauen zahlen stehen in seinen artikeln die wir auch verlinken sowas wie er hat irgendwie vierunddreißig videos gemeldet aber die haben nur,
vier davon auch tatsächlich offline genommen weil diese plattform haben natürlich irgendwelche agbs.
Und um da so ein video offline zu bekommen musst du natürlich entsprechende,
die entsprechenden richtigen juristischen sätze schicken und naja der anwalt des kultur kosmos,
ich habe ja der schreiben gesehen ich sag mal das ist halt ein anwalt der weisheit was er da schreiben muss ich werde mal sehr gespannt,
die betroffenen personen die ja jetzt zum glück oder unglück auf diesen videos also ich denke sehr zum glück auf diese videos nicht erkennbar waren.
Da hingeschrieben hätten ob die in der lage gewesen wären auf englischer sprache ihr anliegen da ausreichend sauber zu formulieren sodass diese plattform nicht sagt wer sind sie,
zeigen sie erstmal ein beweis dass sie das sind oder so das würde mich schon interessieren und wir stellen uns hier natürlich bei solchen sachen auf jeden fall die frage.
So
Ich halte das für sehr unwahrscheinlich dass die videos die bei x hamster und einschlägigen plattformen in diesem kontext veröffentlicht werden,
konsensuell angefertigt wurden es gibt natürlich möglichkeiten wie die das sicherstellen können die könnten ja zum beispiel sagen ok wir schalten diese videos frei,
da muss aber am anfang muss eine person in die kamera blicken und sagen mein name ist so und so und ich bin damit einverstanden dass ich hier gerade gefilmt werde und wir benutzen das als stilistische des mittel aber.
Dass derartige mechanismen sind da nicht.
In kraft und warum ist das interessant finde auch hier mal unter uns oder zwischen uns zu diskutieren ist weil.
Wir,
im rahmen des urheberrechts in der urheberrechtsreform halt auch gesagt haben naja die plattform wenn jetzt auf youtube irgendeine urheberrechtsverletzung stattfindet oder sonstwas dann ist relativ klar dass youtube größten,
das größere ziel dieser plattform nicht der verstoß gegen das urheberrecht ist und dass sie nicht explizit dazu auffordern du du suchst auf youtube jetzt.
Die kategorie camp und irgendwie x wird oder was weiß ich h d trip oder sowas ja die blu-ray oder so das ist eine kategorie die findest du bei youtube nicht,
ja
bei x hamster findest du aber sehr wohl eben eine kategorie für videos die ja letztendlich eine straftat darstellen.
Und einen sexuellen übergriffs und,
x hamster motiviert quasi die täter dazu verdient mit der verbreitung dieser videos geld und hat da noch diese geheimen austausch dinger ja wo sie quasi auch noch einen handel damit,
ermöglichen und da fragt man sich natürlich schon da ist das ist ja wohl irgendwo nicht in ordnung natürlich.
Würde ich mich richtig mich gegen eine plattform.
Haftung oder irgendwelche uploadfilter aber ich denke dass hier diese plattform schon sehr klar dass hochladen derartige videos und auch das anfertigen derartiger videos.
Ermutigen und das finde ich gut.
Ja auf jeden fall ich meine allein schon dadurch wie die plattform sozusagen aufgemacht ist man,
prinzipiell mag das auch für alle porno plattformen gelten,
mag sein dass jetzt hier die ganze ausrichtung nochmal explizit auf dieses ganze tausch ding optimiert ist und damit natürlich ganz andere klientel anzieht.
Aber ich meine natürlich sollte man.
Für das verantwortlich sein was man was man in die welt bringt die frage ist ja nur auf auf auf welcher rechtspartei geschieht das.
Und der vergleich mit dem copyright uploadfilter meine hier kannst du ja jetzt keine originale feststellen und kannst du jetzt hier nicht irgendwie automatisiert testen dass irgendein content,
nicht die rechte verletzt von also nicht die nicht die urheberrechte verletzt von anderen sondern hier geht's ja sozusagen um die inhaltliche bewertung dessen was.
Was genau wird hier eigentlich gezeigt und befindet sich das sozusagen in einem gewissen rechtlichen rahmen.
Das problem hat natürlich auf youtube.
Ja ja aber ich finde tatsächlich also mich interessiert tatsächlich hier der der kontext also irgendwo.
Verläuft eine linie zwischen okay die die lassen nutzer generierten content zu ja aber letztendlich die bieten eine kategorie dafür an.
Also das ist ja schon irgendwie naja also ich finde.
Ich denke nicht dass das dass das unbedingt geduldet werden sollte so wie diese plattform dieses verhalten motivieren und animieren.
Die frage ist nur was ist der rechtliche was ist der richtige weg das rechtlich auch umzusetzen dann fühle ich mich gerade etwas außer zustande da eine passende antwort zu geben.
Also das einzige was mir so einfallen würde wäre tatsächlich okay man erzwingt eine
oder man man macht verpflichtend dass die angeblich das alle in dem video erscheinenden personen vorher dokumentiert auf dem video ihre einverständnis geben das wird jetzt im im zeitalter von deep auch nur noch zwei jahre halten
aber so.
Also wenn du mal durch so wenn du dir mal so eine seite anguckst und dadurch die kategorie schaust dann siehst du da eine ganze reihe an videos die eindeutig illegale inhalte sind und,
wenn sie das wenn das gefaked illegale inhalte sind dann sind sie sehr gut gefaked und dann wäre das auch in ordnung,
das in irgendeiner form ja zu verbrieft das müsst ihr erreichen für diese spanner wenn sie irgendwie fake spanner videos sehen aber offenbar nicht.
Tja also wir sind da auf jeden fall hinterher strafanzeigen sind,
erstattet worden es gibt auch ja.
Vielleicht die eine oder andere möglichkeit den täter dann doch zu identifizieren wäre uns natürlich sehr daran gelegen in dem fall des anderen festivals das monis rache heißt,
ist der täter identifiziert ja der,
war ja so klug mitzuteilen dass er dort gearbeitet hat insofern waren sie dann in der lage den zu identifizieren wie das bei denen gelaufen ist gibt es eine ein sehr ausführliches statement was wir auch verlinkt haben.
Es stellt sich natürlich jetzt weiterhin auch die frage was kannst du gegen sowas machen ich meine das sind beides festivals mit einem sehr,
klaren liberalen und linken anspruch.
Und auch einen anspruch an die achtung der würde
aller teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer was jetzt vielleicht bei anderen festivals ebenfalls der anspruch ist der aber nicht unbedingt so groß geschrieben wird ähm.
Wenn du mal versuchst so versteckte kameras also wenn das jetzt auch verstecken ausgelegte versteckte kameras sind zu finden,
dann schlag hast du aber mit dem ort mit den ohren ne also die dinger sind einfach inzwischen so klein dass heimlich film ganz normale einfach standard risiko ist ne kameras sind
einfach inzwischen findet sich klein insbesondere wenn du ein bisschen glasfaser köpfe davor schiebst oder so ne kannst du
und den den eigentlichen aufzeichnen kopf irgendwo ein bisschen woanders verschwinden lässt kannst du ihn großartiger qualität mit winzig kleinen kameras sehr versteckt filmen.
Und das auch noch in relativ dunklen umgebung.
Genau kann also jetzt eine veranstaltung garantieren dass das auf ihren öffentlichen einrichtungen toiletten oder sonst was nicht passiert nein geht nicht.
Kann das kann das irgendjemand für seine privaträumen garantieren naja im zweifelsfall nur dadurch dass er selber nicht so eine scheiße da anbringt aber wir werden irgendwie versuchen müssen damit einen umgang zu finden.
Und ich denke das wichtigste ist vor allem eine ausführliche,
und ganz klare gesellschaftliche achtung von menschen die so etwas tun und auch von plattformen die daran geld verdienen dass so etwas verbreitet wird.
Ja also.
Dass alles was ich dazu zu sagen habe.
Aber ich finde ich bin mal gespannt das würde mich vielleicht wenn wenn das alles ist was ich dazu zu sagen habe würde mich auf jeden fall mal in euren kommentaren.
Interessieren inwiefern ihr da jetzt vielleicht sage ich mal meine position oder meine vorstellung auch.
Ja vielleicht doppelzüngigkeit seht im vergleich zu was ich in richtung plattformbetreiber haftung in sonstigen fällen urheberrechts verstöße und sonstigem sehr,
oder terror filter und upload-filter und so ziehen das wäre doch vielleicht mal ein schönes thema für eine diskussion.
Ja oder generell natürlich welche welche ansätze für eine handhabung des problems ihr da seht ganz unabhängig von der bewertung deiner position linos.
Ja genau genau also das meine ich ja also wer wer eine position bewertet wird dass er hoffentlich mit alternativen tun aber gut dass er nochmal hinweise darauf hinweist,
für deine stimmung weißt du das nicht nein wir wollen immer nur konstruktive kommentare.
Kommen wir glaube ich jetzt noch kurz zu den kurzmeldungen ne.
Ja bitte kurz.
A warst
der antiviren hersteller hatte schon voll hatte seit längerem einen browser plugin das ein klick stream gesammelt hat das wurde irgendwann veröffentlicht
dann haben sie gesagt okay wir haben das jetzt abgeschaltet und haben aber in wirklichkeit umgeschaltet dass ihr,
antivirus selber jetzt die die das nutzerdaten die die netzwerk daten aufzeichnet und an ein.
Eigens von awards gegründetes unternehmens namens jump shot bietet.
Jump schrott weiterleitet schott hat angegeben sie hätten von über einhundert millionen geräten den klick stream werben irgendwie mit so etwas wie research every click every bye,
also
in diesem in diesem klick stream ist dann drin was weiß ich auf welchem welche google maps suchen was so auf youporn dir angeschaut hast und auf youtube und so weiter weil sie,
vermutlich das war jetzt nicht so ganz in dem bericht von motherboard mit drin aber ich gehe davon aus dass sie für ihren antivirus damit sie in den netzwerk verkehr reinklicken können
einfachen männer mittel machen und zertifikat installieren so dass sie dann eben auch in hatte die ps traffic reinschauen können.
Bei diesem plugin haben sie die ausrede dafür dass sie diesen klick stream gesammelt haben war das ist ein plugin war das vor bösen seiten aus dem internet waren soll ne.
Der sinnvolle ansatz für sowas isst du schickst einfach den leuten die das plug-in haben regelmäßig die liste der bösen seiten im internet ja du schickst ihn einfach eine blacklist ja der schlechte ansatz ist,
jeden einzelnen link den du aufrufen schicken die an dich ja das schöne an dem schlechten ansatz ist der lässt sich monetarisieren.
Und der sinnvolle ansatz eben nicht so sehr
genau das plug-in was sie damals hatten wurde von allen browser herstellern sofort gesperrt nachdem interessanterweise der hersteller der der decoder des plugins von
plus das in seinem blog festgestellt und veröffentlicht hatte und dann haben sie es eben in den antivirus selbst reingezogen.
Oh mann ey.
Die kunden von jump shot also weiß hatte offenbar auch noch irgendwelche interne informationen von james scott die kunden von james haben sie angeschrieben die haben aber relativ einseitig geantwortet und,
außerdem sagen sie ja wir haben für jedes gerät eine device und das ist irgendwie ein hashtag und deswegen sind die daten anonym ist aber natürlich ein klacks ja,
einfaches beispiel wenn er die google maps sachen drin sind ne,
in der regel suchen leute von google maps wege von sich zuhause davon ihrer arbeit irgendwohin ja und dann hast du halt schon die adresse der leute mit anderen worten diese daten sind natürlich nicht.
Also sind anonymisiert aber eben sehr einfach zu dir anonymisieren gewesen interessanterweise nachdem diese story.
Öffentlich wurde hat jump shot sehr schnell den betrieb komplett eingestellt.
Wirklich.
Wenn man irgendwie also ich glaube wenn du auf jump schott hat kommen gehst steht da einfach nur jump shot operations funk you.
Die twitter-account gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Genau das habe ich auch gerade gesehen in den twitter-account gibt's auch nicht mehr ja bärenstark die haben also wäre doch mal schön wenn das öfter so laufen würde bei solchen bei solchen berichten.
Es ist aber auch wirklich echt hardcore womit die leute auch immer wieder durchkommen also gerade diese ganzen antiviren systeme das sowas als partys sich reinzuholen ist einfach generell schwierig.
Ja absolut also antiviren echt.
Das ist ein großes großes problem also man kann eigentlich nur generell generell vor waren sich auf so einen quatsch einzulassen wenn ihr angst habt vor schadsoftware dann kümmert euch darum.
A das system auf dem aktuellen stand zu halten b die system eigenen schutzmechanismen vor schadsoftware zu nutzen also hier windows defender oder,
diese apple funktion nur aus aus dem app store und vertrauenswürdigen quellen zulassen.
Deaktiviert office makros ja ist das größte problem und klickt nicht auf jeden.
Auf jeden mist nutzen vernünftigen nicht wie ins genannten vernünftigen blogger und ihr habt dieses problem in weiten teilen.
Aus eurem aus eurem bedrohungsszenarien entfernt
da irgendwelche viren scanner die sich tief ins system einnisten jeden prozess überwachen selber eine riesige angriffsfläche sind da fand es eigentlich abzuraten und,
ebenso von browser plugins
ich bin ja auch immer überrascht wenn man mal so bei anderen leuten am computer guckt dass sie dann irgendwie zwei zeilen browser plugin symbole in ihrem firefox haben wo du dir auch denkst du leute wisst ihr überhaupt was diese plugins also.
Das ist auch da kriege ich ja da schlacker ich ja auch mit den ohren aber da da gibt es wirklich einige leute hier wirklich so eine so ein.
Plug-in polytop trauma haben wurde irgendwie gar nicht mehr weiß wie viele plugins da in den browser hängen und die haben alle vollständigen zugriff auf mehr oder weniger alles was da passiert leute leute.
Das in zunehmenden maße nicht mehr weil natürlich auch diese ganzen plugin schnittstellen in letzter zeit halt zurückgefahren werden,
haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen dass sozusagen auch blogger darunter leiden weil sie eben nicht mehr diesen tiefen zugriff bekommen eben damit eben auch nicht so viel aufgeforstet werden kann das ist schon auch eine antwort auf ein reales problem und auch an der stelle eben schwer
zu lösen wenn du irgendwie sicher haben will sicherheit
wenn du sicherheit haben willst wenn du sicher haben willst dann musst du irgendwo auch immer auf einen gewissen komfort verzichten der dir dann eben einfach nicht mehr möglich ist.
So dann gibt's eine gute nachricht.
Wie gut.
Er
Also ausreichend für jingle gute nachricht.
Ich weiß ich also mailbox dot org ist in russland nicht gesperrt ich glaube ende ende der durchsage ich hab's nur mit drin weil wir in der letzten sendung besprochen haben.
Und das jetzt sozusagen wieder zurück gezogen wurde.
Ja das verfahren von dieser roskos ist.
Hallo.
Irgendwie so ausgegangen dass mailbox erstmal in russland weiter agieren darf.
Ja das heißt ja.
Ich werde schon zum nächsten thema.
Achso ja mach doch mal.
Hasse corona virus tim.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ey ich bin glaub ich der einzige der noch der noch irgendwie nach wie vor sich darüber amüsieren kann wie alle jetzt irgendwie hier in diese corona panik verfallen.
Ähm aber wir werden auf jeden fall alle sterben,
irgendwie es gibt eine reihe an studien und irgendwelche aktivisten haben diese studien dann in einer,
aktion alle aus dem urheberrecht geklaut und und frei veröffentlicht damit die welt weiß,
was mit dem corona virus los ist,
ich persönlich also ich denke grundsätzlich natürlich das ist immer wichtig für die freiheit der wissenschaft einzutreten und in dem kontext sich auch die aktion,
grundsätzlich habe ich aber erstmal gerade ich höre genug von corona virus ehrlich gesagt von mir aus können wir uns wieder um andere können wir uns wieder einen anderen virus widmen.
Der grippe zum beispiel hat irgendwie zwanzig siebzehn fünfundzwanzigtausend leute in deutschland getötet keine sau interessiert.
Ja gut
da gibt's aber im prinzip halt auch schon wege sich davor zu schützen da ist man dann in anführungsstrichen selber schuld während der halt diese neue variante des corona virus ist ja eine gruppe von viren.
Immer noch so das problem hat dass man noch kein gegenmittel
dafür hatte das wahrscheinlich auch noch bis ins nächste jahr dauern wird um sowas anzulegen einerseits und andererseits dass eben diese türkische inkubation zeit halt wirklich ein problem ist dass er also zwei wochen in einem schlummern kann und das eben schon durchaus ausreichend grund für die große hektik.
Ich sehe ich habe es mit einem zu tun der das licht gesehen hat.
Na ja ich meine du argumentiert hier wie man so schön sagt außer einer privilegierten position heraus so.
Ich würde sagen lieber tim ich argumentiere gerade aus einer äußersten risiko position heraus aber das ist was für nach der sendung.
Gut ähm und jetzt haben wir noch termine.
Wir haben termine einen termin der ist so kurz wollen wir dafür musik machen.
Weiß ich nicht vielleicht nicht.
Machen wir so am samstag den zweiundzwanzigsten februar richtet die digitale gesellschaft schweiz ihren winterkorn aus und zwar in der roten fabrik in zürich,
es gibt ein vielseitiges programm eher im politischen bereich,
tickets könnt ihr bekommen.
Ich gucke gerade mal was wir da so haben es gibt vier räume.
Programm also vier tracks sehr viele vorträge und die tickets gibt es online mal gucken was steht da jetzt.
Die seite ist aber langsam dreißig franken normal,
mitglied zwanzig neumitglied fünf also fünf siebzehn wird man mitglied und professional hundertfünfzig also ihr könnt zum winterkorn stress zwanzig zwanzig am samstag den zweiundzwanzigsten zweiten zwanzig zwanzig um,
elf uhr in zürich in die rote fabrik gehen um dort den winter kongress der digitalen gesellschaft zu besuchen.
Ja da gibt's auch ein sehr breites thema angebot wie ich der webseite entnehmen kann.
Dann wünschen wir euch viel spaß.
So lina ist jetzt machen wir aber schluss ja.
Ich glaube die haben das mit treto x gemacht so schön wie das hier aufgearbeitet.
Könnte sein ja sehr wahrscheinlich sogar.
Ja wir sind wir sind durch ne also auch tatsächlich durch.
Dann bleibt uns jetzt nur noch uns freundlich zu bedanken oder.
Ja genau weil es eine lange sendung aber musste mal sein wir.
Hören uns dann bald wieder nächste sendung wird ein spezial soviel schon mal vorweg und ja mal gucken wann wir so weitermachen.
Vielen vielen dank dass ihr so lange zugehört habt und bis denn tschau tschau.
Ciao.